SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR CITY
MINISTRATION -- COULD NOT HAVE A
QUORUM SOARING START OFF.
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE A RESTORED ON
ISSUE NUMBER -- ONE DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE OUR SPRING FISCAL
LETTER CLIMATE AND
SUSTAINABILITY
.
IT'S OUR DUTY CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS PLEASE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR COOPER MY
NAME IS JULIE ACROSS NINE THE
DEPUTY COMMANDER I'M A POLICY
FOR SECOND.
TELL ME COMMITMENTS LACKEY
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
PROBLEMS PROBLEMS.
GO AHEAD I'M SORRY NO PROBLEM.
HI MY NAME IS JULIE ACROSS TIME
THE DEPUTY COMMISSIONER FOR
ADMINISTRATION AND LICENSING
SERVICES AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE.
SITTING NEXT TO ME IS MICHAEL
PETERSON THE DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
OVER THE CLIMATE AND
SUSTAINABILITY BRANCH WERE
SEEKING YOUR APPROVAL TODAY FOR
OUR SPRING FINANCED LETTER WHICH
REQUEST TO POSITIONS AND FOUR
HUNDRED FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS.
TO ADDRESS CLIMATE IMPACTS ON
INSURANCE.
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER LAURA WHO
WAS ELECTED THIS PAST JANUARY
HAS MADE CLIMATE CHANGE POLICY A
HIGH PRIORITY BASED ON THIS
POTENTIAL TO DESTABILIZE
INSURANCE MARKETS.
THE LAST TWO YEARS THE STATE HAS
SEEN SEVERE FIRES WHICH ALIGNS
WITH CLIMATE CHANGE PREDICTIONS
FOR WESTERN FORESTS.
AS A RESULT SEA ICE FACING
URGENT CONCERNS RELATED TO THE
AVAILABILITY AND AFFORDABILITY
OF INSURANCE IN HIGH RISK AREAS.
IT IS CRITICAL FOR CD I'D HAVE A
PROACTIVE FRAMEWORK TO ADDRESS
MORE FREQUENT SEVERE CORRELATED
PERILS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WHICH ARE LIKELY TO CONTINUE.
THIS PROPOSAL LINES OF THE
COMMISSIONERS VISION THAT CITY I
WILL BE WELL POSITIONED TO TAKE
PROACTIVE STEPS TO PROMOTE
RESILIENCE AND REDUCE
ANTICIPATED FUTURE LIABILITIES
WHICH WILL BRING DOWN THE RISK
FOR THE INSURER AND THE COST FOR
THE CONSUMER.
THE CAPACITY OF THE DEPARTMENT
TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE IS
MORE CRITICAL THAN EVER WE WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AND YES
VOTE ON OUR PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU FINANCE [inaudible]
PHILADELPHIA.
BRAIN WITH A FORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
WE DON'T HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON
THIS PROPOSAL.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION -- PLEASES
GOT THE GOAL THE COMMISSIONER
ESTABLISHING THIS NEW BRANCH.
THANK YOU -- WHEN IS MICHAEL
PETERSON AND THE DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER AND CLAIM IT'S AN
ABILITY FOR COMMISSIONER LARA OF
THE GOALS HERE TO HAVE A MORE
PROACTIVE FRAMEWORK FOR
PROVIDING RECOMMENDATIONS? TO
ADDRESS CHANGES IN THE
MARKETPLACE ESPECIALLY FOR
HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE AND HI
WILDFIRE AREAS AND ALSO TO
IMPLEMENT.
BILLS SUCH AS SB THIRTY FROM.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IT WAS THE WITH
THE CAMPFIRE THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
CAN MAGNIFY OUR EXISTING
DISASTERS HOW YOUR OFFICE
HELPING FOR PUBLIC POLICY.
WITH THESE NEW STAFF.
IN THE WILD FIRES FROM THE LAST
TWO YEARS WE'VE SEEN THAT THERE
IS AN INSURANCE IMPACT TO CLAMOR
RELATED CATASTROPHE SUCH AS THE
CAMPFIRE AND SO.
ON THIS BRANCH WILL MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO WHETHER
THERE INNOVATIVE PRODUCTS OR
INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES THAT WILL
BRING DOWN RISK AND INCREASE
AVAILABILITY AND AFFORDABILITY
OF INSURANCE IN THOSE AREAS.
SINCE WHEN THE COMMITTEE.
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK ON
THIS ITEM.
THERE WAS A OF A QUORUM STILL
SOLD WILL COME BACK AND DO
THROUGH ITEM WE GET A QUORUM.
THIS WILL NOT A NUMBER -- TWO
HEALTH OF ALL POLICIES
.
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
AFTERNOON.
AT GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I MY
NAME IS LOUISE BEDS WORTH HAVING
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL.
AND I'M JOINED HERE BY JULIA
KAPLAN WHO'S THE MANAGER OF OUR
HEALTH AND ALL POLICIES TEAM.
WE'VE REQUESTED THREE POSITIONS
AND FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY AND
I'M GOING SUPPORT FOR THE
GENERAL FUND. TO CONTINUE THE
EXISTING HEALTH AND ALL POLICIES
PROGRAM ARE HIGH UP.
AT THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL.
THE HYATT PROGRAM IS BEEN A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BETWEEN
PHILANTHROPY AND THE STATE SINCE
ITS INCEPTION.
IN.
TWENTY TEN FOUNDATIONS OF
INVESTED OVER FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS TO DATE AND SUPPORT THE
HOW TO SUPPORT THE HIGHER
PROGRAM.
BUT EVEN CLEAR FROM THE
BEGINNING THAT THEIR INVESTMENT
IS IT INTENDED TO SUPPORT START
UP AND NOT LONG TERM PROGRAM
MANAGEMENT.
THEREFORE ABSENT STATE SUPPORT
THIS PROGRAM WILL WIND DOWN AT
THE END OF THIS YEAR.
HI UP PROVIDE HIGH UP SUPPORTS
IMPROVING COMMUNITY CONDITIONS
THAT AFFECT HEALTH SUCH AS
ACCESS TO HEALTHY FOODS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY INCLUDING WALK ABILITY
AND ACCESS TO PARKS AND SAYS
STABILITY OF EDUCATIONAL WORK
FORCE AND HOUSING RESOURCES.
ALL OF THESE ARE KNOWN AS THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
HI UP WORKS ACROSS PROGRAMS AND
DEPARTMENTS TO INTEGRATE HEALTH
IN EQUITY LEVERAGING ON GOING
PROGRAMS AND INVESTMENTS TO
IMPROVE CONDITIONS IN WHICH
PEOPLE LIVE THE PHILOSOPHY IS
NOT TO CREATE NEW PROGRAMS BUT
RATHER TO ASSIST EXISTING
PROGRAMS.
WITH ACHIEVING MULTIPLE GOALS.
THIS APPROACH IS WIDELY
RECOGNIZED THE PUBLIC HEALTH
FIELD AND IS RECOMMENDED BY THE
INSTITUTE OF MEDICINE AMERICAN
PUBLIC HEALTH ASSOCIATION AND
OTHERS IT IS A NEW PROGRAM FOR
STATE GOVERNMENT HENCE THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH LAND TO BE TO
GET IT STARTED.
CALIFORNIA'S THIS FIRST STATE
LEVEL GOVERNMENT IN THE COUNTRY
TO ADOPT THIS APPROACH AND IS
WIDELY HELD UP AS A MODEL THAT
IS BEING TRACKED AND REPLICATED
BY THEIR JURISDICTIONS.
BECAUSE THE CROSS EACH AGENCY
NATURE OF HIGH UP THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER THAT ESTABLISH THE PROGRAM
SET IT UP AT THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL.
WHICH IT WAS ESTABLISHED TO
FACILITATE CROSS AGENCY
COLLABORATION.
SINCE THAT TIME THE STATUS
PROVIDED OPERATING EXPENSES AND
EQUIPMENT AND THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE WHICH IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION HAS SERVED AS A
FISCAL AGENT PROVIDED HIGH UP
STAFFING USE AND PHILANTHROPIC
DOLLARS.
I UNDERSTAND THE SUBCOMMITTEE
HAS HAD SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT
SPECIFIC OUTCOMES OF THIS WORK
BOTH IN THE PAST AND THE FUTURE
INSIDE LIKE TO TAKE JUST A FEW
MINUTES TO DESCRIBE.
SOME CONCRETE OUTCOMES SO -- I'M
A PAUSE RIGHT HERE'S BECAUSE
DOUBLES RECORD OKAY.
SEVERAL LOCAL PLACE COOPER.
HI TO LACKEY HI NAZARIAN.
SO WE'RE GOING.
SO SO.
I HAVE A MOTION ARE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR FOR ITEMS -- EXCUSE ME.
LARA CALENDAR [inaudible]
EVERY.
ARE YOU EVERY ITEM EXCEPT FOR
ITEMS TWO TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR ON THE FOLLOWING CALENDAR
IS OUR MOTION.
WELL FIRST THE SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE COOPER HI TO LACKEY.
NAZARIAN WICKS.
WE'LL TAKE A THESE ARE
INDIVIDUALLY -- A NUMBER TO ROLL
CALL PLEASE COOPER HI.
HELP ME MOTION FOR SOME SORRY
[inaudible]
ALSO GONNA [inaudible]
AND HI COOPER HI TO LACKEY
[inaudible]
NAZARIAN WICKS [inaudible]
HI I YOUR LOCAL FOR A NUMBER.
TWENTY THREE AND CAL OSHA PLEASE
[inaudible]
ALSO GET.
COOPER HI.
TO LACKEY.
NAZARIAN WICKS.
MAKE A MOTION FOR ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
TWENTY FOUR ALSO GONNA.
COOPER HI CHIU.
LACKEY NO.
NAZARIAN WICKS [inaudible]
IF MR.
OAKLAND DEAL WITH MISTER -- TO
FOR THE VOTE EARLY CALENDAR --
ALL THE ITEMS SUPPOSE WE JUST
LISTED.
TWO TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
TWO WE'LL GO BACK -- TO ISSUE
NUMBER -- ONE RECOGNITION TO
ADOPT THE SPRING FISCAL LETTER.
THEIR MOTION.
K. ROLL CALL PLEASE COOPER HI
[inaudible]
TWO LACKEY.
NAZARIAN WICKS.
FIVE CANNELLA CONTINUE ON WITH
OTHER NUMBER TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- YES SO I WANTED TO
TAKE A FEW MINUTES TO JUST TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE CONCRETE
ACHIEVEMENTS OF THIS WORK --
SINCE THE START OF THE PROGRAM
AND THEN WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
FOR TWENTY TWENTY AND BEYOND --
SINCE TWENTY TEN HIGH UP IS
PROVIDED THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNSEL WITH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO DEVELOP HEALTH AND
EQUITY GRANT CRITERIA AND
MEASUREMENTS TO ENSURE THAT OUR
CLIMATE CHANGE INVESTMENT
PROGRAMS.
ARE ADVANCING OUTCOMES ALIGNED
WITH THE STATE'S PUBLIC HEALTH
INEQUITY GOALS.
HYPE IS ALSO PROVIDED THE SAME
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT
TO OTHER DEPARTMENTS INCLUDING
ASSISTING CALTRANS IN THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION TO INTEGRATE HEALTH
CRITERIA AND TO GRANT
APPLICATIONS.
DEVELOPING HEALTH APPENDIX TO
THE STATE'S REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN GUIDELINES.
PROVIDING A PROMISING PRACTICES
THAT REGION'S CAN USE TO PROMOTE
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES THROUGH
THEIR LEGALLY MANDATED PLANNING
PROCESS SEES.
AN EXISTING STATE PARKS THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE.
AND WITH SIMILAR APPROACHES.
MUCH OF THIS WORK IS OFTEN
CONTAIN THROUGH MULTI AGENCY
ACTION PLANS THAT INCLUDE
QUANTITATIVE GOALS AND METRICS
TO ADVANCE POSITIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES FROM I'M GOING STATE
ACTIVITIES.
SINCE TWENTY TEN HYPE IS ABOUT
TWELVE ACTION PLANS THAT ADDRESS
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION FOOD
PARKS AND OTHER ASPECTS OF
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES -- EACH OF
THESE IS ENDORSED BY THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNSEL AT THE
COUNCIL'S PUBLIC MEETINGS AND
STAFF PROVIDE PROGRESS UPDATES
IN THIS PUBLIC FORUM AT LEAST
TWICE PER YEAR.
AND SEVERAL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
ADVOCACY GROUPS ARE INVOLVED IN
FREQUENT AND PUT.
SOME OF THESE PLANS INCLUDE A
PARKS AND HEALTHY TREE CANOPY
PLAN WHICH WAS ADOPTED LAST YEAR
THAT ESTABLISHES QUANTITATIVE
GOALS TWO ENTRIES URBAN KEEP
TREE CANOPY.
AND THIS PLAN INVOLVES
COMMITMENTS FROM FOURTEEN
DIFFERENT STATE DEPARTMENT SAID
INCLUDE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
THE CONSERVATION DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION AND GENERAL
SERVICES.
IN ADDITION WE'VE COMPLETED TO
HEALTHY FOOD ACCESS PLANTS.
WHICH HELPED OUT TO DEVELOP TO
TEST ABOLITION THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF FARM TO FORK WHICH IS
AN ONGOING PROGRAM OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE.
MOST RECENTLY THE HEALTH AND ALL
POLICIES TEAM HAS RESPONDED TO
REQUESTS FOR MULTIPLE AGENCIES
FOR ASSISTANCE IN BUILDING THEIR
CAPACITY TO BETTER BETTER SERVE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
ADDRESS INSTITUTIONALIZED RACISM
AND DISPROPORTIONATE ALREADY.
AND A MAJOR IMPLEMENTATION STEP
OVER THE LAST YEAR HAS BEEN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE GOVERNMENT
ALLIANCE AND RACIAL EQUITY
CAPITAL COHORT.
WHICH IS SUPPORTING TWO HUNDRED
STATE EMPLOYEES AND LEADERS
ACROSS NINETEEN DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES TO EXAMINE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS OF
THEIR PROGRAMS AND PRACTICES.
I UNDERSTAND THE HISTORY OF
INSTITUTIONALIZED RACISM IN
CALIFORNIA AND DEVELOP ACTION
PLANS TO TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
AND INEQUITIES IN THEIR OWN.
PROGRAMS.
I AM USING RESULT BASED
ACCOUNTABILITY WERE DEVELOPING
GOALS TIME LINES AND
QUANTIFIABLE PERFORMANCE
MEASURES FOR THIS WORK.
AS WE LOOK FORWARD THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL WILL CONTINUE --
TO AS TO DEVELOP THE HEALTH AND
ALL POLICIES TEAM IT WILL HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY WITH THESE
POSITIONS BEING STATE FUNDED TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
STRATEGICALLY ALIGNED.
WITH OUR WORK AT THE COUNCIL AND
THE BROADER GOALS OF THE STATE.
AND IN PARTICULAR WE'RE LOOKING
WE WILL BE CONTINUING THE CARE
CAPITAL COHORT AS I MENTIONED
NINETEEN DEPARTMENTS CAN ARE
CURRENTLY PARTICIPATING.
AND WE HAVE AT LEAST NINE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE LOOKING TO
DO -- SORRY SEVEN OTHER
DEPARTMENTS LOOKING TO START IN
THE FUTURE.
WERE SABOTAGING IN IMPLEMENTING
STATE LEVEL METRICS AND
INDICATORS TO TRACK PROGRESS --
AND WE WILL BE DEVELOPING
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES TO
EVALUATE THIS WORK AND AND AND
IT'S SALAS ACCOUNTABILITY
MECHANISMS WE CAN DOCUMENT
PROGRESS THROUGH OUR REGULAR
COUNCIL MEETINGS AND IN OUR
ANNUAL REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THEN WE WILL CONTINUE TO
IMPLEMENT OUR ON GOING ACTION
PLANS.
INCLUDING DEVELOPING DATA AND
MAPPING TOOLS TO IDENTIFY URBAN
HEAT ISLANDS TREE CANOPY AN
OVERLAY WITH THE DISADVANTAGE OF
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AS PART
OF OUR PARKS IN TREE CANOPY WORK.
WE'RE DEVELOPING A NEW PLAN ON
HEALTHY TRANSPORTATION TO
SUPPORT CALTRANS DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION STATE PARKS PUBLIC
HEALTH.
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AND MANY
OTHER PARTNERS WHICH WILL SECURE
NEW COMMITMENTS FROM DEPARTMENTS
TO WORK TOGETHER TO REDUCE
BICYCLE AND PEDESTRIAN INJURIES
AND FATALITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE.
HERE THIS AFTERNOON WE'RE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU ALL
HAVE.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
AT TEN WEBER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ADMINISTRATION SUPPORT
THIS PROPOSAL.
HELPING A POLICIES AS SHOWN
SUCCESS -- IN COURT EIGHT WHAT
WAS THE AGENCIES TO IMPROVE
HEALTH AND CALL AND EQUITY THAT
WE BELIEVE THESE RESOURCES WILL
OUT TASK FORCE TO CONTINUE
FEATURES SUCCESS AS DESCRIBED
BERMAN.
LL.
A QUESTION ONE OF THE STAFF WAS
STAFF LOSER GRANT FROM THE
FOUNDATION THAT FUNDED THEM.
IT THE INITIAL INVESTMENT WAS
ALWAYS INTENDED TO BE A PROOF OF
CONCEPT AND FROM THE BEGINNING
THE UNDERSTANDING WITH THE
FOUNDATIONS HAD BEEN THAT
ULTIMATELY THESE PROGRAMS WILL
BE TAKEN IN AS A STATE FUNDED
MISSION.
WAS REALLY INTENDED TO BE A
PROOF OF CONCEPT AND SO THE
FOUNDATIONS ARE VERY PLEASED
WITH THE SUCCESS.
HI UP IS ACHIEVED TO DATE AND
FEEL THAT IT'S TIME TO START
TRANSITIONING THAT WORK IN TO
THE STATE STRUCTURE.
HAVE ANY OF THE SGC HEALTH IN
EQUITY GOALS.
MISSED THE RESULT WILL POLICY
DIRECTION OF THE LEGISLATURE --
YEAH I CAN SPEAK TO THAT I I
THINK THAT THE MAJORITY OF THE
WORK THAT WE HAVE DONE IS
HELPING INDIVIDUAL DEPARTMENTS
FULFILL THEIR MANDATES MANY OF
WHICH ARE LEGISLATIVE SUCH AS
PROMOTING.
HEALTH AND EQUITY CO BENEFITS
THROUGH THE CLIMATE CHANGE
INVESTMENTS AND SO WE'VE DONE
QUITE A LOT OF WORK ACROSS
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES WITH THEIR
INVESTMENTS WE'VE.
SUPPORTED HEALTH AND EQUITY
APPROACHES IN OVER TWO BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF GRANT MAKING
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
THERE ARE ALSO SOME SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES WHERE THE HEALTH AND
ALL POLICIES TASK FORCE THROUGH
A PUBLIC INPUT PROCESS.
I IDENTIFIED RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT THEN WERE TURNED INTO
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS THAT WE'VE
AND HELPFUL FELL AND SO ONE OF
THOSE IS THE EXAMPLE THAT LOUISE
SHARED AROUND BRINGING A HEALTH
AND EQUITY PERSPECTIVE TO THE
SEATS REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
GUIDELINES.
THAT WAS RECOMMENDED BY THE
PUBLIC THE IDEA WAS SHARED
THROUGH HEALTHAND ALL POLICIES
AND THEN THERE WAS LEGISLATION
PASSED AFTER THAT HAPPENED THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
APPROACH THE HEALTH AND ALL
POLICIES TEAM AND ASK FOR OUR
ASSISTANCE WITH IMPLEMENTATION.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MR.
TO ASK YOU TO JUST RESPOND TO
THE STAFF COMMENTS.
ABOUT THE POSITIONS NOT HAVING
ONGOING VALUE.
THE BCP NOT INCLUDING ANY
CONCRETE EXAMPLES OF FUTURE
WORKLOADS TO JUSTIFY EXTENDING
THE EFFORTS OF STATE RESOURCES
JUST RESPOND. TO TO WHAT WAS
LAID OUT BY STAFF.
YEAH I MAY THINK THAT THE SPRING
FINANCE LETTER OUTLINES A NUMBER
OF SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES THAT WE
WILL -- FOR PHIL I THINK OVER AT
WE'VE DEVELOPED WE ALSO HAVE A
HAND THAT WE CAN PROVIDE WE
PROVIDED TO STAFF OF A NUMBER OF
THE OUTCOMES THAT HAVE BEEN
ACCOMPLISHED OVER THE PAST AND
WHERE WE'RE LOOKING IN THE
COMING YEAR.
AND AND YEARS AHEAD I THINK THE
FOCUS REALLY IS A LOT ON THE
GOVERNMENT ALLIANCE AND RACIAL
RACE IN EQUITY WORK.
A CONTINUING TO ASSIST
DEPARTMENTS IN DOING THE
CONCRETE REALIZATION OF HEALTH
IN EQUITY OUTCOMES IN
PROGRAMMATIC WORKING GRANT
GUIDELINES -- AND THEN REALLY A
STRONG FOCUS ON MEASUREMENT OF
OUTCOMES AND PROGRESS TRACKING
TO INFORM THE WORK GOING FORWARD.
ALTHOUGH IT OPEN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT THIS POINT.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND JDS HERE ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA THE STATE WIDE HEALTH
CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY COALITION.
IN SUPPORT OF OP OURS PROPOSAL
FOR HEALTH FALL POLICIES IN
ISSUE TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU KATHY MUST FOR WITH
THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL AS WELL --
PH I OVER THE LAST NINE YEARS
HAS SEEN THE SUCCESS AND THE
VALUE OF THIS PROGRAM AND WE
THINK THAT THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL --
A WALL SHOWING THAT WORKS TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE THIS WORK AND
WE THINK THAT'S A GOOD IDEA AT
THIS POINT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JUDY
ROBINSON ON THE SUSTAINABILITY
INSTANCES MANAGER FOR SACRAMENTO
COUNTY BUT I'M HERE SPEAKING AS
ONE OF THE MEMBERS OF A DYNAMIC
CROSS SECTOR HEALTH TEAM CALLED --
DESIGNED FOR AFTER SACRAMENTO
WHERE WE'VE BEEN DOING WORK
ACROSS SACRAMENTO.
THE REGION CALIFORNIA AND
ACTUALLY THAN THE THE COUNTRY IN
ADVANCING HEALTH AND BUILT
ENVIRONMENT WORK.
I WANT TO SAY THAT THE WORK THAT
HEALTH ON IN ALL POLICIES HAS
DONE IS LANDMARK -- FEW THINGS
HAVE BEEN AS IMPACTFUL AS HEALTH
AND ALL POLICIES AND ADVANCING
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
AND TO THE LOCAL LEVEL WORKING
AT THE STATE LEVEL WAS STATE
DEPARTMENTS IS VERY IMPORTANT
BUT IF IT'S NOT IMPLEMENTED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL THAT WE DON'T
HAVE HEALTHY COMMUNITIES.
AND SO THE CONSIDERATION AND OUR
SUPPORT IN IN RECOGNIZING
APPROVING THE FUNDING THAT'S
BEFORE YOU IS IS GREATLY
ENDORSED.
IT'S HIGHLY COLLABORATIVE AND
SOME OF THE GRANT PROGRAMS THAT
WERE BEING REFERENCE THROUGH
CALTRANS WE WORK WITH LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENTS AND
THEIR COUNTERPART PUBLIC HEALTH
THAT ARE UNDER RESOURCE IN UNDER
FUNDED. TO EMBED HEALTH INTO
THESE PROJECTS THAT WERE IT NOT
FOR HEALTH AND ALL POLICIES
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
LINDA TENER WHAT'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA OF HANNAH THANK
HEALTH NETWORK WE JUST WANNA
LENDER SUPPORT FOR THE HEALTH
AND ALL POLICIES PROGRAM WE
REALLY THINK THE THE PROGRAM
REALLY UNITES A LOT OF SEEMINGLY
UNRELATED POLICY AREAS TO REALLY
CRAFT.
SOLUTIONS AND MORE EFFICIENT --
PROCEDURES FOR HOW TO MAKE --
EXISTING PROGRAMS WORK BETTER
FOR THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE REALLY FEEL LIKE THIS PROGRAM
CAN SERVE AS A MODEL YOU KNOW
FOR OTHER STATES TO BETTER
INTEGRATE THEIR WORK AS WELL --
SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT --
YOU KNOW THE EXISTENCE OF HIGH
UP AND ALL OF THE WORK THAT THEY
HAVE DONE IN THE PAST ENDING TO
CONTINUE THAT MOMENTUM FORWARD
SO WE RESPECTFULLY I REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'RE THE WHOLE THIS
ITEM OPEN SO NEXT MONDAY ITEM
NUMBER THREE PRECISION MEDICINE
.
CHECK UBER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON KATE GORDON ON THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH.
AND IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE
TO TALK ABOUT OUR PRECISION
HEALTH AND MEDICINE WORK FOR
CALIFORNIA AND JOINED BY
ELIZABETH BACHA WHO RUNS THAT
PROGRAM.
THE CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE TO
ADVANCE PRECISION MEDICINE HAS
GROWN FROM ITS INCEPTION BOB WAS
ANNOUNCED IN THE STATE OF THE
STATE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN IT FROM
A THREE MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM
TO A FIFTY THREE MILLION DOLLAR
PROGRAM.
STILL THE ONLY ONE OF ITS KIND
REPRESENTING REALLY UNIQUE
PARTNERSHIPS IN THE STATE
BETWEEN THE STATE.
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS NONPROFITS
AND INDUSTRY PARTNERS.
THE PROGRAM SINCE ITS INCEPTION
HAS BEEN A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAM WITH INITIAL YEARS --
GRANTS GOING TO UC SANTA CRUZ
AND UCSF FOR DEMONSTRATION
PROGRAMS AND PRECISION MEDICINE.
IN THE SECOND YEAR OF ITS
INCEPTION WITH AN ADDITIONAL TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDS SIX
MORE PROJECTS AWARDED SUTTER YOU
UC DAVIS CHAUDHRY CEDAR SINAI.
UCSF AGAIN AND UC IRVINE IRVINE.
THE NEXT YEAR ANOTHER TEN
MILLION ADDED WITH SOME STANFORD
UC SAN DIEGO AND USE YES SOUTH.
ADDED AS PARTNERS.
IN STATURE THAN I DO HAVE COPIES
OF THE STATUTE WITH ME -- IF
YOU'D LIKE TO HAVE THEM.
THE PROGRAM IS ESTABLISHED WITH
OPR THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH HAVING THE FULL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE PROGRAM
IN A COUPLE OF IMPORTANT THINGS
IN THE STATUTE ONE IS.
THE STATUTE GIVES OPR THE
AUTHORITY TO CONTRACT OUTSIDE OF
A PR FOR ADMINISTRATION AND
OTHER ASPECTS OF THE PROGRAM.
AND ON THE THIS STATUTE ALSO
REQUIRES THAT GRANTS THE
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM HAVE
SOME I GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY SO
INCLUDE BOTH SOUTHERN AND
NORTHERN -- GRANTEES WHICH I
THINK WE HAVE ACCOMPLISHED VERY
WELL.
BUT WITHIN THAT PROGRAM AND HOW
IT'S BEEN AROUND SINCE THE
BEGINNING OPR HAS BEEN THE
FISCAL AGENT OF THE PROGRAM WE
UNDER AUTHORITY IN THE STATUTE
DID CONTRACT WITH UCS UP AS THE
LEAD TO ADMINISTER A FEES.
WE ALSO CONTRACTED WITH UC AVIS
I SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS A
FINANCIAL OFFICER AND LAWRENCE
BERKLEY LAB IS THE LEAD ON THE
ASSET INVENTORY WHICH IS A
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS ARE THERE
SEVERAL CONTRACTS THAT WE'VE
DONE FOR MINISTRATION.
OVER THE YEARS IN THIS PROGRAM.
THE PROGRAM HAS GROWN AS I SAID
FROM THREE MILLION INITIALLY TO
FIFTY THREE MILLION DOLLAR
PROGRAM AND ONE THING THAT WE'VE
DONE IT -- PR -- UNDER ELIZABETH
DIRECTION -- IN THAT TIME AS THE
PROGRAM'S GROWN IS TO REALLY
LOOK AT WHAT I IS WORKING AND
ISN'T WORKING IN THE POLICY
FRAMEWORK WHAT DO WE NEED TO
SUPPORT THE ON GOING INTERESTS
ARE PRECISION MEDICINE AND
HEALTH.
IN THE STATE THROUGHOUT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IN THIS GROUP.
HAS BEEN A A WIDE RANGING SORT
OF STAKEHOLDER GROUP INCLUDING
UCSF AND MANY OF THE OTHER
ECONOMIC INSTITUTIONS WE WORK
WITH PATIENT EXPERT HELP THIS
VERY EXPERTS FOUNDATIONS.
THIS GROUP PUT TOGETHER REPORT
THAT CAME OUT LAST YEAR THAT
MADE UP SOME CENTRAL
RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDING THE IT
JUST TALKED ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF CROSS INDUSTRY AN INSTITUTION
COLLABORATION TO REALIZE THE
POTENTIAL.
OF THIS PROGRAM ALSO.
MADE THE POINT THAT THIS IS
BEYOND ANY ONE INSTITUTION.
THIS GROUP OF WIDER STAKEHOLDERS
DID MAKE A RECOMMENDATION LAST
YEAR THAT THE PROGRAM MOVED OUT
OF ITS CURRENT POSITION IN THE
STATE IN INTO MORE OF AN
INDEPENDENT INSTITUTE.
THAT PROPOSAL WAS REJECTED LAST
YEAR BY THE LEGISLATURE SO AFTER
THAT PROPOSAL WAS REJECTED THE
PROGRAM REVERTED TO ITS PLACE
WITHIN THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH WHERE IT IS NOW.
I SHOULD SAY THAT -- WE LAST
WEEK MET WITH OUR BROUGHT
ADVISORY GROUP WHICH INCLUDES
UCSF U. S. C. STANFORD UCLA UC
SAN DIEGO UC DAVIS AND LAWRENCE
BERKELEY NATIONAL LAB.
THIS ADVISORY GROUP ALL MET LAST
WEEK OR YES WEDNESDAY OF LAST
WEEK AND HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
SUPPORTIVE OF IT YOU KNOW THOUGH
STILL I THINK.
LIKE THE INSTITUTE CONCEPT HAVE
BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROGRAM IN ITS CURRENT ITERATION
AT AT PR -- AND THEY ARE FULLY
STATE FULL STEAM AHEAD ON THE
SUBSTANCE OF THE PROGRAM
INCLUDING DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS --
THIS YEAR ON SOME REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUES FOR INSTANCE
ACT REDUCING CANCER DISPARITIES
IN UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS IS
ONE OF THE KEY DEMONSTRATIONS
THIS YEAR.
OVERALL THESE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL FOR CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP WRONG PERSON HEALTH
AND MEDICINE.
HAVE ALREADY YIELDED BENEFITS
ACROSS ALL OF THE YEARS THAT
PROGRAM OF FUNDS HAVE BEEN GOING
OUT TO THESE INSTITUTIONS.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU TO CONTINUE THE PRO
GRAHAM IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE LOOK FOR TO QUESTIONS
THANK YOU FINANCE [inaudible]
LL [inaudible]
THE COMMITTEE.
GOING OVER THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAU
CHAIRMAN COOPER AND HIS LOVELY
TO BE HERE WITH ALL OF THE REST
OF YOU -- I SENT YOU MY LETTER
SO YOU'LL BE RECEIVING IT BUT
I'M GOING TO TAKE A QUICK GANDER
AND AND RUN THROUGH IT.
I AM SPEAKING TO YOU IS THE
FOUNDER OF THE LATINO CANCER
INSTITUTE BASED IN SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA AND A RECENT AWARD HE
WITH THE STANFORD CANCER
INSTITUTE OF THE CALIFORNIA
INITIATIVE. TO ADVANCE PRECISION
MEDICINE GRANT NOW I SPEAK HERE
IS A COMMUNITY PARTNER.
IN THIS ENDEAVOR AND I SPEAK AS
A CANCER SURVIVOR WHO NOW SPEAKS
FOR PEOPLE.
WHO DON'T KNOW THEY HAVE A VOICE?
I SPEAK AS A VETERAN TV
JOURNALIST OF FORTY THREE YEARS
WHO RECEIVED A LATINO SPIRIT
AWARD FROM THE LATINO CAUCUS OF
THIS.
LATINO PLEDGES OF THIS
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE AND I
SPEAK AS A CONCERNED CITIZEN
WHO'S TAX PAIRED A DOLLARS FUND.
IS VERY KEY INITIATIVE THAT CAN
IMPACT ALL OF OUR HEALTH THAT OF
OUR FAMILY OUR COMMUNITY AND IN
FACT CALIFORNIA.
THE LATINO CANCER INSTITUTE
WORKS SPECIFICALLY AS A NATIONAL
NETWORK OF LATINO CANCER SERVICE
AGENCIES. TO DEVELOP AND SHARE
BEST PRACTICE PROGRAMS SUCH AS
THE ONE ADVANCED BY OUR CIA PM
PROPOSAL TO COLLABORATE WITH
RESEARCH.
SUCH AS THE C. I. A. M. PROPOSAL
DOES IN COLLABORATING WITH
RESEARCH AND TO PROMOTE POLICIES
THAT ACTUALLY IMPACT OUR ABILITY
TO DIMINISH EVEN ELIMINATE
CANCER RISK IN THE LATINO
COMMUNITY -- THESE ARE STEPS
THAT WE HOPE TO DEMONSTRATE IN
OUR SEE IBM OF FUNDED MODEL IN
MONTEREY COUNTY WHICH WE WILL
HOPE WILL INSPIRE STATEWIDE
POLICY.
MY ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN BRINGING THE
ISSUE OF PRECISION MEDICINE
TOWARD NETWORK OF RESEARCHERS
AND CANCER ADVOCATES. FOR FEAR
THAT MUCH OF OUR POPULATION
EITHER CITIZEN OR UNDOCUMENTED
WILL BE UNABLE TO UTILIZE THIS
CUTTING EDGE MEDICINE DUE TO
LACK OF KNOWLEDGE COST AND
ACCESS.
HENCE THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
WILL ONLY ENHANCE IT EXACERBATE
DISPARITIES SUFFERED BY UNDER
RESOURCE LOW INCOME AND LANGUAGE
CHALLENGE COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
SUCH AS MONTEREY COUNTY WERE ONE
IN FOUR LIVES IN POVERTY AND
WHERE 50% OF THE POPULATION
MAKES LESS THAN FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
NOW AS I UNDERSTAND UNDERSTOOD
GOVERNOR BROWN'S MANDATE A WITH
THIS INITIATIVE AND THE GOAL OF
THE INITIATIVE.
ALL CALIFORNIANS SHOULD BE ABLE
TO GET PRECISION MEDICINE CARE
WHEN NEEDED.
OUR PROPOSAL IS MEANT TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT AND PROVIDE A
MODEL FOR THE STATE.
I AM NOW CONCERNED.
BECAUSE IT APPEARS TO ME THAT
THERE IS SOME QUESTION ABOUT HOW
THE CI A PM WILL CONTINUE TO
OPERATE UNDER WHOSE AUTHORITY.
I HAD HOPED AS PROPOSED LAST
YEAR THAT IT BECOME AN
INDEPENDENT AUTHORITY SO THAT
THE INTEREST OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA BE ADDRESSED FIRST
AND FOREMOST.
I HAD ALSO PLANNED TO CALL FOR
COMMUNITY REPRESENTATION ON THAT
AUTHORITY BOARD.
IF THAT IS NOT POSSIBLE I ASK
THAT THE CIA PM.
AND IT'S FUNDING MANDATE STAY
LOCATED IN AND OPERATED BY THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WHICH
SHOULD WORK EQUALLY ACROSS
SYSTEMS PARTNERSHIPS POWER
BROKERS AND IN SOME CASES.
THE HISTORICALLY POWERLESS I
FURTHER ASKED THAT ANY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE HAVE AT LEAST FOUR
DIVERSE COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVES FROM NORTH SOUTH
AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS WORLD REPRESENTATIVES.
I FEAR THAT IF ANYONE
INSTITUTION IS IN CHARGE THIS
WILL ULTIMATELY COST CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS IN ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
MINE.
THE OPPORTUNITY HAVE A SAY IN
WHAT WHERE AND HOW RESEARCH
RELATED PRECISION MEDICINE
QUESTIONS ARE DETERMINED AND
STUDIED.
AND PRACTICAL AS WELL AS
SCIENTIFIC SOLUTIONS FOUND.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ANYONE OF YOU ANSWERING ANY ONE
OF YOUR QUESTIONS I HOPE YOU
RECEIVED MY EMAIL SOON.
AND HAS MY PHONE NUMBER AND MY
ADDRESS AND ALL THE PERTINENT
DETAILS IN IT THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING.
THANK YOU.
WE CONTINUE HAVE CONCERNS WITH
HOW THIS DECISION TO MOVE THIS
PROGRAM WAS MADE.
GIVEN THE LEGISLATURE'S ACTION
LAST YEAR RESPECT TO CONTINUE
THIS DISCUSSION IN BUDGET
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
OTHER RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADOPT
THE BUDGET BILLING WHICH REQUIRE
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO BECOME THE PROGRAM
MINISTRY -- THE REMAINING
FUNDING IS OUR MOTION.
SO MOVED CAN I SAY JUST QUICKER
ABSOLUTELY BOB THE SO I JUST
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO HAS
BEEN WORKING ON THIS AND AS I'VE
SAID I THINK EVERY YEAR THIS.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE I'M A BIG
SUPPORTER OF WHAT OUR STATE IS
DOING AROUND.
PRECISION MEDICINE AND IN
PARTICULAR BIG SUPPORTER OF WHAT
UCSF HAS BEEN DOING WHICH IS
WIDE TO SUPPORT OF THE ASSEMBLY
POSITION LAST YEAR AND I DO
THINKTHAT IS.
STILL THE WAY WE SHOULD GO AYE
MY GUESS IS THIS WILL BE A
DISCUSSION AND CONFERENCE BUT
WITH THAT.
I'M HAPPY.
TO SUPPORT THE CHAIRMAN'S
MEASURE BUT THIS IS AND NO WINS
ANY INDICATION WITH REGARD TO
THE WORK THAT I KNOW HAS BEEN
DONE IN RECENT MONTHS ON THIS BY
THE ADMINISTRATION.
SO THAT A MOTION THAT IS A
MOTION.
MOVE A SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE.
COOPER HI TWO HI LACKEY
[inaudible]
NAZARIAN WICKS.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER -- FOUR UNCLAIMED
PROPERTY
.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NAME IS JENNIFER URBAN I'M
WITH THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE.
THE ISSUE BEFORE YOU INCLUDES
TWO REQUESTS RELATED TO THE
CLAIM PROPERTY PROGRAM.
THE FIRST REQUEST IS FOR
PERMANENT RESOURCES TO CONTINUE
TO PERFORM AUDITS OF HOLDERS TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA UNCLAIMED PROPERTY
LAW.
WHICH WILL RESULT IN INCREASED
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY TO BE
REUNITED WITH ITS RIGHTFUL
OWNERS SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN THE SCO HAS
BEEN APPROVED CONTINUATION OF
THE SAME RESOURCES.
ON A LIMITED TERM BASIS.
THIS WORKLOAD IS ONGOING AND
SUPPORTER WITH PERMANENT
RESOURCES TO ENSURE HOLDERS
CONTINUE TO REPORT AND REMIT
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY. TO SCO FOR
THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF RETURNING
TO ITS RIGHTFUL OWNER.
THE RESOURCES WILL ALSO ASSIST
HOLDERS IN CREATING UNCLAIMED
PROPERTY POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
FOR IDENTIFYING AND REPORTING
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY IN SUBSEQUENT
YEARS.
THE SERVER REQUEST IS FOR
PERMANENT RESOURCES TO CONTINUE
IDENTIFYING AND PREVENTING
FRAUDULENT UNCLAIMED PROPERTY
SUBMISSION.
THE MISSION CLAIM FORMS FROM
BEING PAID.
IN TWO THOUSAND TEN ELEVEN U. P.
D. IDENTIFY FRAUDULENT CLAIMS
PAID ERRONEOUSLY TOTALING TWO
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH INDICATED THAT MORE
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS WERE BEING
PAID OUT THE NEW PT WAS ABLE TO
IDENTIFY. TO HELP REDUCE FRAUD
THE S. YOU RECEIVED PERMANENT
AND LIMITED TERM RESOURCES AND
ESTABLISH THE FRAUDULENT CLAIMS
PREVENTION AND DETECTION PROGRAM.
WITH THESE APPROVED -- WITH
THESE RESOURCES YOU PRETTY HAS
PREVENTED AN AVERAGE OF SEVEN
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AND FRAUDULENT CLAIMS
FROM BEING PAID OUT OVER THE
PAST SIX YEARS.
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
FINANCE.
SERRA COVER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- THE PROPOSAL IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SUPPORTS
CONTROLLERS ONGOING EFFORTS
TOWARDS ADDRESSING HOLDER
COMPLIANCE IDENTIFYING
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS AND RETURNING
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY TO OWNERS
[inaudible]
HELLO.
THE QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMON THIS ITEM.
CORRECT NATION'S TO PROVE HIS
BUDGET ADOPT A SPRING FISCAL
LETTER THEIR MOTION.
THE MOTION.
FROM WHAT WILL HAVE A THREE LAST
MISTER LACKEY.
SO WE HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'LL
WAIT TO VOTE ON THAT ITEM OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THIS NEW ADDITION REVIVED THE
OFFICE OF DIGITAL INNOVATION.
SEE AN H..
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
I'M MICHAEL WILL CONTAIN THE
SPECIAL ADVISER ON INNOVATION
AND DIGITAL SERVICES IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
I AM IN THE REQUEST BEFORE YOU.
AND I HAVE WITHIN EIGHT JULIE
LEE THE UNDERSECRETARY OF THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY.
THE REQUESTED FOR YOU IS FOR
THIRTY SIX POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS AND FIFTY POSITIONS IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY AND
FOURTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING TO ESTABLISH AN
OFFICE OF DIGITAL INNOVATION.
WHERE'S THE PREACHER OF THE
SUPPORT FOR THE CONCEPT IN THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
I THINK WE ALL RECOGNIZE THAT
WE'RE NOT MEETING THE
EXPECTATIONS OF CALIFORNIANS.
ARE CONTINUING TO FALL FURTHER
BEHIND AND THAT IS THE RISK OF
THE STATUS QUO.
OUR CONCERN IS WITH THE PROPOSED
SIZE OF THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
AND THE REMOVAL OF THE
PROCUREMENT AUTHORITY.
AND WHAT THE REQUEST IS TRYING
TO DO IS IS -- REALLY A CULTURAL
SHIFT IN THE WAY THAT STATE
GOVERNMENT OPERATES. TO
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE WAY THE
INFORMATION SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED TO CALIFORNIANS.
A SHIFT FROM FOCUSING ON
PROGRAMS AND DEPARTMENTS TO
PEOPLE.
ABOUT THOSE THAT ARE UTILIZING
GOVERNMENT SERVICES.
AND THOSE THAT ARE PROVIDING THE
SERVICES.
AND THIS IS PART OF AN
INTERNATIONAL SHIFT THAT STARTED
WITH THE U. K. DIGITAL SERVICE
AS REPRESENTED IN THE THE U. S.
BY THE US DIGITAL SERVICE IN
EIGHTEEN HALF.
WHICH IS AT AN OFFICE OF THE
GENERAL SERVICES ADMINISTRATION.
THIS FOCUSES ON A TEAM BASED
APPROACH MULTI DISCIPLINARY TO
TACKLE COMPONENTS AND JUST AS AS
WE LEARN AND TEST WITH USERS.
WE NEED DESIGNERS HER WELL
VERSED IN USER EXPERIENCE
SOFTWARE ENGINEERS PRODUCT
MANAGERS AND BUREAUCRACY HACKERS.
THE CONCEPT IS TO PARTNER WITH
THE DEPARTMENTAL STAFF AND IN
FACT TO INCLUDE DEPARTMENTAL
STAFF IN THE OFFICE.
WE HAVE EXPERIENCE HIRING STAFF
AND WE CAN BRING THIS OFFICE UP
QUICKLY.
FUNDAMENTALLY WHAT'S MOST
IMPORTANT AT THE BEGINNING IS TO
HAVE THE RIGHT LEADER.
WE HAVE A NETWORK OF ADVISORS
THAT INCLUDES ALL OF THE TOP
PEOPLE DOING THIS RIGHT NOW
INTERNATIONALLY.
WE'RE GETTING RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THOSE FOLKS FOR THE RIGHT
PERSON TO LEAD THIS OFFICE.
THAT PERSON THOUGH NEEDS TO
BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HAVE IMPACT ON HOW
CALIFORNIA OPERATES.
AND THEY NEED TO SUFFICIENT SIZE
OFFICE IN ORDER TO DO THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE MULTIPLE TEAMS.
START TO DEMONSTRATE THE
POTENTIAL AND GENERATE
ENTHUSIASM AND BY AND THE
PROJECTS WILL BE SELECTED ONCE
WE HAVE THE DIRECTOR.
THE ONE THAT'S THAT'S MENTIONED
IN THE AGENDA IS NOT ONE THAT WE
WOULD START WITH WHICH IS D. M.
V. WAIT TIMES AND THE REASON FOR
THAT IS WE ALREADY HAVE AN
EFFORT UNDER WAY WITH.
WITH THE DMV SO WE HAVE A STRIKE
TEAM THERE WE HAVE A LOT OF OF
DIFFERENT CONSULTANTS AND
THEY'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS THE
THE WAIT TIMES.
THIS OFFICE ISN'T GOING TO BE UP
UNTIL MID FALL IS MY MY BEST
GUESS RIGHT NOW.
AND BY THEN WE NEED TO BE WAY
DOWN THE ROAD WITH THE ENVY
ADDRESSING DMB WAIT TIMES.
THERE MAY WILL BE ASPECTS OF THE
DMV THAT THIS OFFICE CAN ADDRESS
AS IT COMES UP BUT I WOULDN'T
WANT THIS TO BE THAT THE FOCUS
OF THE OFFICES I AS IT COMES UP
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
TED RATE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL AS
BUDGETED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
L. L..
BRENT METZ KALEO WE RAISE A
NUMBER OF ISSUES FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION AT THE LAST
HEARING ON THIS ISSUE -- WE WILL
RAISE THEM AGAIN IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME -- BUT WE DID WANT TO
NOTE THAT IF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
DOES ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE -- MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER HOW BEST TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT OF THE OFFICES
ACTIVITIES AS WELL AS TO
EVALUATE ITS EFFECTIVENESS GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE.
ARE GOING UP ON A PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE.
KEVIN KILLING DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR INTERNET
ASSOCIATION WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
REQUEST.
CALIFORNIANS EXPECT INTERACT
WITH GOVERNMENT THROUGH DIGITAL
CHANNELS INCLUDING WEBSITES
EMAIL MOBILE APPLICATIONS.
BY BUILDING DIGITAL SERVICES
THAT MEET THEIR NEEDS CALIFORNIA
TO MAKE THE DELIVERY OF OUR
POLICY IN PROGRAMS MORE
EFFECTIVE.
THE OFFICE OF DIGITAL INNOVATION
WILL USE AN INCREMENTAL FAST
PACED STYLE OF SOFTWARE
DEVELOPMENT TO REDUCE THE RISK
OF FAILURE OF THESE PROJECTS.
THE GOAL TO GET SOFTWARE INTO
USERS HANDS EARLIEST POSSIBLE
GIVE THE DEVELOPMENT TEAM
OPPORTUNITIES TO ADJUST BASED ON
USER FEEDBACK ABOUT THE SERVICE.
WE AGREE THE HEAD COUNT FIFTY IS
ESSENTIAL TO ENSURE CROSS
FUNCTIONAL TEAMS WITH A VARIETY
OF EXPERIENCE TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEMS.
SO WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
REQUEST AND THINK THE ASSEMBLY
FOR ANY SUPPORT IT CAN PROVIDE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF ROB GROSS BECAUSE
REPRESENTING AMAZON -- TODAY
WOULD LIKE TO LEARN MYSELF WITH
THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE INTERNS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS MR
WILKENING AND CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR NEW POSTER -- AMAZON AS YOU
KNOW MISTER CHAIR IS ONE OF THE
WORLD'S MOST CUSTOMER OBSESSED
COMPANIES AND CUSTOMER OBSESSION
IS SOMETHING THAT WE THINK THIS
STATE -- HAS BEEN LACKING IN
CERTAIN AREAS AND SO THIS
INITIATIVE IS SOMETHING THAT
WERE QUITE SUPPORTIVE OF AND
BELIEVE THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE GOOD WORK WHAT DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY IS CURRENTLY DOING
THE WORKING ON MAJOR IT SYSTEMS.
VERY SIGNIFICANT THINGS THIS
OFFICE IS FOCUS IN A DIFFERENT
MANNER AND THAT'S PROVIDING
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIANS THE
CONSTITUENTS.
AND WE THINK ULTIMATELY THAT IF
YOU HAVE BETTER DELIVERY TO
CONSTITUENTS YOU'RE ACTUALLY
GONNA SEE SOME SAVINGS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I KNOW IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO HAVE SUCH A
DYNAMIC ANALYSIS ASSOCIATED.
WHEN CUSTOMERS EXPECT TO BE
CONNECTING THE OTHER MOBILE
DEVICES AND THAT'S OUR ONLY
ACCESS TO GOVERNMENT THEY DON'T
HAVE VACCINATIONS THEY DON'T
HAVE DESKTOPS I MEAN IT WE NEED
TO BE LOOKING AFTER THAT LENDS
IN OUR OPINION?
AND WE ARE EXCITED ABOUT THIS WE
ALSO AGREE AND APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT THERE'S RISK
ASSOCIATED.
BUT IN ORDER TO MAKE THE
SUCCESSFUL WE DO BELIEVE AS WELL
THAT THE FIFTY POSITIONS THE
AMOUNT THAT THE MINISTRATION HAS
REQUESTED IS NECESSARY TO GET
THAT STARTED.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU.
THE GOAL IS PROPOSAL MAKES SENSE
BUT THE POLLS EXECUTION IS
RUSHED.
WE WANT TO SEE THIS OFFICE START
OFF A STRONG FOUNDATION AND GROW
OVER TIME.
IF YOU CAN DEMONSTRATE THE VALUE
YOUR PROMISING YOU HAVE NO
PROBLEM RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FROM US IN FUTURE
YEARS.
SO AS FAR AS A RECOMMENDATION
GOES WE'RE GONNA PROVE THE TEMP
POSITION FOR THE OFFICE OF THIS
REALIZATION.
RUN APPROVED TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR GENERAL FUND BEGIN
INNOVATION REVOLVING FUND.
RUDOLPH PLACE WHICH REAL BILL
LANGUAGE TO ESTABLISH THE OFFICE
BUT DO NOT INCLUDE LANGUAGE LINE
THE OFFICE TO HAVE STANDALONE
PROCUREMENT AUTHORITY.
IS OUR MOTION.
THE TO TO IF COULD I MAKE A
QUICK COMMENT SURE -- SO I VERY
MUCH AGREE WITH -- THE GOALS OF
THIS OFFICE AND AND I'M EXCITED
ABOUT IT.
I THINK THIS IS A SUBCOMMITTEE
THAT A SCENE TIME AFTER TIME --
TECHNOLOGY NOT USED WELL
THROUGHOUT GOVERNMENT AND THE
IDEA THAT WE'RE GONNA TRY TO
INNOVATE IN THE SPACE IS VERY
VERY EXCITING -- I DO THINK THAT
WE NEED.
TO SEE THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
STAFFING AND FUNNY LEVELS AS WE
GO THROUGH IT AND AND WITH THAT
I'M HAPPY.
TO HELP MAKE THE MOTION TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD.
MY HOPE IS THAT THIS OFFICE IS
ABLE TO PROVE VERY QUICKLY ITS
VALUE AND AND WITH THAT LONGER
TERM I'M OPEN TO SUPPORTING
LARGE AMOUNTS BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO IT TO REPORT BACKS.
IF YOU OBSERVE THE SUBCOMMITTEE
EVERY TWO WEEKS OR SO YOU WILL
FIND MANY MANY EXAMPLES WHERE I
THINK THIS OFFICE COULD MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND SO MY HOPE IS.
WILL SEE THAT ON A REGULAR BASIS
IN THE COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS
AND WE LOOK FOR TO HOPEFULLY
SUPPORTING -- EXPANSION THIS
OFFICE THAT -- MY HOPE IS AS WE
EXPAND THIS OFFICE WE WILL BE --
WILL BE ABLE TO CUT BACK ON
EXPENDITURES AND OTHER AREAS --
THAT'S A LONG TERM HOPE AND
WE'LL SEE THAT OF THE COUNTRY.
I'LL SECOND THAT MOTION CAN WE
HAVE WILL HELP PLEASE CONFIRM.
HI JUNE I'D LACKEY NAZARIAN
FLICKS.
LET'S MOVE ON UNDER.
SIXTY TWENTY TWENTY WE CAN
BEFORE WE DO THAT FOR VOTE.
IT WILL GO BACK AND VOTE ON
ISSUE NUMBER.
FOUR AS THEIR MOTION.
THAT'S OKAY PROPERTY FUN.
SECOND.
CAKE ROLL CALL PLEASE COOPER HI.
TO LACKEY NAZARIAN FLEX TIME
[inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUSTIN
HOW ARE FROM THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY AND WITH ME IS
DAIS COULD TARGET THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA CLING COUNTS
INSIST WE TWENTY OFFICE.
AND THE ITEM BEFORE YOU TODAY IS
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REQUEST
FOR AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY FOUR
MILLION TO BOLSTER THE STATE'S
OUTREACH EFFORTS RELATED TO THE
UPCOMING -- DECENNIAL CENSUS AT
FIFTY FOUR MILLION IS PROPOSED
TO BE SPENT ON A VARIETY OF WAYS
THIRTY MILLION IS PROPOSED TO BE
SPENT FOR OUR PUBLIC AND MEDIA
RELATIONS R. F. P..
AND THAT IS CURRENTLY -- UNDER
REVIEW WITHIN THE OFFICE -- TEN
MILLION IS SET ASIDE FOR TO
BOLSTER OUR DOOR TO DOOR
CANVASSING EFFORTS WERE GOING TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
OUR COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
PARTNERS DURING THE NON RESPONSE
FOLLOW UP PERIOD -- SIZE WE SEE
EVENTS ON FULL DURING ACTION
RACING PROCESS WILL THEN
ALLOCATE OUT AT THOSE RESOURCES
SO THAT THEY CAN GO DOOR TO DOOR
AND PROVIDE THE NECESSARY --
CAMPUS SCENE -- WITHIN THE HARD
TO COUNT COMMUNITIES -- IT
INTENTIONAL TWO MILLION A SET
ASIDE FOR SECTOR OUT REACH OF
THAT ONE MILLION IS HEADING
TOWARDS EDUCATION ANOTHER
MILLION IS HEADING FOR OUR OTHER
SECTORS INCLUDING HEALTH CARE.
FINALLY WE HAVE SIX MILLION THAT
SET ASIDE FOR OUR STATEWIDE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THIS IS TO TARGET OUTRAGE
TOWARDS VERY SPECIFIC
DEMOGRAPHIC POPULATION GROUPS.
AND WE'VE ALREADY MADE SOME
RELATED TO OUR STATEWIDE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND WE'RE PROPOSING TO ADD AN
ADDITIONAL SIX MILLION -- TO
TARGET SPECIFIC GROUPS -- AND
THERE'S ALSO AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT FIRST
EVER.
AND CALIFORNIA HOUSING
POPULATION SAMPLE NUMERATION
WHICH IS GONNA BE CONDUCTED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS A
DEMOGRAPHIC RESEARCH UNIT --
THAN THIS AT THE AT THE PURPOSE
WE TALK BEHIND THAT IS TO HELP
SUPPORT OUR REACH -- AND THE
VALUATION EFFORTS AS WELL AS
IMPROVE -- THAT AND REVIEW THAT
INDETERMINATE ADVOCACY OF USING
ADMINISTRATIVE RECORDS -- FOR
POPULATION ESTIMATES AS WELL AS
PER IMPROVE THE STATE'S OVERALL --
POPULATION ESTIMATE PROCESS SO
WITH THAT -- THE DIRECTOR AND I
ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL RELATED TO THE
FIFTY FOUR MILLION [inaudible]
YEAH.
FINANCE AMAZON WERE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I JUST WANNA MAKE ONE
COMMENT QUICKLY ABOUT.
AND THE STAFF COMMENTS TO DELAY
THE SURVEY -- UNTIL AFTER THE
CENSUS PERIOD I JUST WOULD NOT
THAT WE WOULD HAVE CONCERNS OF
PUSHING THAT OUT TOO FAR AFTER
THE CENSUS PERIOD I THINK THE
LONGER THAT WE WAIT TO DO IT --
THE MORE CHALLENGES WE WILL
FACING GATHERING THIS
INFORMATION SO I'D BE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH STAFF ON
I'M KIND OF A DATE FOR THAT --
EXTENSION.
THANK YOU FINANCE I'M SORRY L.
L..
QUESTION THE COMMITTEE MISTER.
TO SUFFERS ONE MORE THANK
EVERYONE FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
SO -- A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS --
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT WHAT IS THE ADEQUATE
SUFFICIENT LEVEL OF FUNDING THAT
WE NEED IN THIS AREA.
AND I'M WONDERING IF THE
ADMINISTRATION IF YOU COULD
EXPLAIN HOW YOU GOT AT THE
NUMBER THAT YOU DID WHY YOU
THINK THAT IS SUFFICIENT.
AND GIVEN TO THE RECOMMENDATION
IS ABOUT EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
SHORT OF WHAT THE MAJOR CBO
SENSES COLLISION IS LOOKING.
FOR HELP US UNDERSTAND.
KIND OF HOW YOU GOT TO THIS
NUMBER AND I'M NOT.
I AM NOT SAYING ONE WAY THE
OTHER WHICH IS THE RIGHT NUMBER
BUT I WOULD ASK ALL PARTIES TO
REALLY HELP US UNDERSTAND HOW WE
JUSTIFY THE PROPER LEVEL FUNDED
HERE.
YET I MEAN THAT IS THE ULTIMATE
QUESTION AT THE END OF THE DAY
HUNDRED WHY FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS OR TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR QUESTION.
RIGHT WHAT IS THE RIGHT NUMBER
AT THE END OF THEDAY AND TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
PRETTY FRANKLY IS I CANNOT TELL
YOU WHAT A CORRECT NUMBER IS AND
WE LOOKED AT AND HOW MUCH TO
PROVIDE ON A PER HARD TO COUNT
POPULATION BASIS.
AND WHEN LOOKING AT THAT WE ARE
HOVERING SOMEWHERE AROUND NINE
TO TEN DOLLARS RIGHT NOW
CURRENTLY -- ON A POLE HARD TO
COUNT POPULATION BASIS ON HOW
MUCH WE'RE SPENDING PER PERSON
IF THAT IS THE RIGHT NUMBER.
I CAN'T I I DON'T KNOW -- IT YOU
KNOW THE AMOUNT OF OUTRAGE THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE IS GOING TO BE
BASED UPON A VARIETY OF FACTORS
THAT YOU KNOW INCLUDING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE OUTREACH
MATERIALS -- THE TRUSTWORTHINESS
OF THE MESSENGERS FOR DELIVERING
THOSE THINGS HOW MANY TIMES DO
WE HAVE -- TO REACH OUT AND
CONNECT WITH THE HARD TO COUNT
POPULATION IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THEY PARTICIPATE COMPLETELY
IN THE UPCOMING CENSUS -- THIS
IS NOT BEEN DONE ON THIS LEVEL
BEFORE -- AND WITHIN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WITH THESE VARYING --
POPULATION GROUPS AND ALL THE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES THAT ARE NOW
IN FRONT OF US RELATED TO THE
CENSUS -- SO.
I'M. TO MAKE OUT.
YOU KNOW A LONG ANSWER SHORT I
DON'T KNOW AND I CAN'T GIVE YOU
A SPECIFIC ANSWER.
AND THEN SOME AND I THIS NEXT
QUESTION IS PROBABLY RELATED TO
THAT BUT WE HAVE NO IDEA IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS WHETHER THE
SUPREME COURT IS GOING TO COME
DOWN AND UPHOLD THE CITIZENSHIP
QUESTION.
CURIOUS WHAT SORT OF CONTINGENCY
PLANNING THERE MIGHT BE.
IF THE WORST CASE SCENARIO
OCCURS AND HOW HOW ARE YOU
THINKING ABOUT THAT.
WELL AND AND MAYBE THE DIRECTOR
LIKE TO CHIME IN A LITTLE BIT ON
THIS I KNOW THAT SHE HAS
MENTIONED BEFORE THAT YOU KNOW
WE WE ARE PROCEEDING AS IF THE
BILL IS ALREADY BEEN WRONG AND
WE CAN'T HONORING IT SO WE ARE%
PROCEEDING AS THOUGH PEOPLE.
ARE ALREADY THINKING THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE INCLUDED AND AND WE
HOPE IT'S NOT ULTIMATELY BUT IF
IT IS WE ALREADY HEADING DOWN
THE PATH ASSUMING THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE INCLUDED SO THAT WE
CAN TRY TO COMBAT -- THAT
QUESTION AND I PROVIDE THAT
MESSAGING -- TO ARE HARD TO COME
POPULATIONS SIMILAR THIS IS A
LEVEL OF FUNNY THAT YOU THINK IS
APPROPRIATE EVEN ASSUMING THAT
THAT QUESTION COMES YEAH AT THIS
POINT IN TIME WE THINK IT'S A
WHAT WE ARE PROPOSING WE BELIEVE
IS APPROPRIATE -- AS AS WE GO
THROUGH THE SUMMER MONTHS WE'RE
GONNA BE WORKING ON WHAT WE CALL
OUR IMPLEMENTATION PLAN SO WE
FUNDED ALL OF OUR PARTNERS OUT
THERE -- AT VARYING LEVELS AND
WE'RE GONNA BE CONVENING ABOUT
TWENTY SEVEN I BELIEVE --
IMPLEMENTATION WORKSHOPS OVER
THE COURSE OF THE SUMMER WERE WE
GOING TO DRILL DOWN INTO MORE
BRAIN YOUR LEVEL OF WHAT EXACTLY
ARE THEY CAN BE DOING AND HOW
ARE THEY SPENDING THAT MONEY.
LIKE WHERE THEY CAN BE PLACING
QUESTIONNAIRE ASSISTANCE CENTERS
WHERE THEY CAN BE PLACING KIOSK
HOW ARE THEY STAFF IN THOSE
THINGS IN THIS IS THAT WE'RE
GONNA BRING ALL OF OUR PARTNERS
TOGETHER WHETHER IT'S THE
COUNTIES -- ARE ADMINISTRATIVE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ARE STATEWIDE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS OUR
MEDIA CONTRACTOR THAT WE CAN SEE
WHO'S DOING WHAT AND WHERE WE
CAN PARTNER PEOPLE UP WHERE WE
NEED.
TO AND THEN WE'LL BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THAT POINT IN TIME
WHETHER OR NOT THERE ARE ANY AND
ALL MISSIONS AND EVERYONE'S.
PLANS IS THERE A PARTICULAR
POPULATION GROUP IS THERE A
PARTICULAR AREA IN THE STATE
THAT WE SOMEHOW MISTER WE JUST
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH FUNDING TO
REACH.
UNFORTUNATELY WE WILL NOT KNOW
THAT UNTIL WE GET TOWARDS THE
END OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR TOWARD
SEPTEMBER AND OCTOBER TIME FRAME.
GOTCHA WELL JUST.
TO CONCLUDE MY PERSPECTIVE -- I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
MINISTRATION AS WELL AS THE
BUDGET COMMITTEES AND NOW SYSTEM
THE NUMBER THAT THEY PUT OUT
HERE.
I CERTAINLY KNOW JUST WITHIN THE
LAST DAY THEIR FAN.
A NUMBER OF REACTIONS OF THE
COMMUNITY ABOUT WHETHER THIS IS
THE RIGHT NUMBER -- I BELIEVE
THAT EVERYONE REALLY BRINGS GOOD
FAITH AND WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS IS FUNDED THE WAY IT
OUGHT TO BE AND I THINK WHAT I
WOULD ASK.
ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS BOTH
THE ADMINISTRATION BUT ALSO THE
STAKEHOLDERS IS TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND HOW TO JUSTIFY WHAT
IS THE RIGHT NUMBER BECAUSE FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE.
I THINK THE ANSWER YOU GAVE IS
ALSO QUESTION I WOULD POSE TO
THE ADVOCATES OF LIKE WHAT IS
THAT CORRECT NUMBER -- MY HOPE
IS AS I SPOKE TO THE CHAIR
EARLIER ABOUT THIS IS WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO HOLD THIS ITEM OVER
JUST BRIEFLY. TO GIVE A LITTLE
TIME FOR THAT MAY TURN OUT THAT
THE NUMBER THAT'S BEING PROPOSED
IS THE RIGHT NUMBER -- AS
SOMEONE WHO VERY MUCH WANTS AS I
THINK WE ALL DO TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE COUNTING EVERYONE I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE WE GET IT RIGHT.
I DO ALSO THINK THERE WAS A
LITTLE BIT OF MISCOMMUNICATION
ABOUT THE ROLE OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE IN THIS COMMITTEE AND
WHERE COMMUNICATIONS WENT TO AND
MY HOPE IS THAT WE CAN JUST GET
SOME FOLKS IN A ROOM AND JUST
REALLY TALK IT OUT -- BEFORE WE
GET TO A FINAL NUMBER BUT WE ALL
KNOW THAT THE DOWNSIDE RISK OF
OF NOT SPENDING ENOUGH FUNDS IS
VERY VERY INTENSE AND SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT.
IF THE WORST CASE SCENARIO COMES
TO BE WE HAVE A CITIZENSHIP
QUESTION ON THE CENSUS -- WE
HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN A
LOT OF COMMUNITIES I DON'T WANT
US TO UNDER ESTIMATE WHAT WE
NEED FOR THIS SO -- SO WITH THAT --
LOOK FOR TO FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS AND AGAIN I KNOW
THAT EVERYONE IS TRYING TO GET
TO THE RIGHT NUMBER AND AND
APPRECIATE THAT WORK.
MISS WICKS.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN I JUST WANNA
LET MYSELF WITH -- SEVEN NUMBER
CHOOSE COMMENTS AS WELL AND
ASKED THAT WE HAVE LEAVE THIS
OPEN -- AT IMPORTANT ACCURATE
COUNT IS CRITICAL FOR MANY MANY
MANY REASONS -- I DO SHARE THE
CONCERN OBVIOUSLY ON THE
CITIZENS SHIP QUESTION I WANNA
MAKE SURE WE GET TO THE RIGHT
NUMBER I KNOW IT'S DIFFICULT TO
FIGURE THESE THINGS OUT -- BUT
WOULD ASK ALL EVERYONE ON HIS I
THINK AGAIN WORKING ALL IN IN
GOOD FACE. TO MAKE SURE WE GET
THAT NUMBER RIGHT -- I THINK
IT'S CAN BE VERY IMPORTS I TO
ASK THAT WE LEAVE THIS OPEN.
YEAH I HAVE A QUESTION REAL HOW
MUCH OTHER STATES ARE SPENDING
ON OUT REACH.
I THINK THE MOST A MINNESOTA
MIGHT BE PUTTING TWO MILLION I
BELIEVE NEW YORK.
AS THEY ASK FOR FORTY THINK THE
ONLY PROOF TWENTY OKAY BUT I
HAVEN'T SEEN HOW IT.
CAME OUT THIS TWENTY YEAH.
YEAH THAT'LL ADD I WANNA USE OF
A NUMBER EARLIER NINE TO TEN
BUCKS A VOTER.
HER HEART ACCOUNT. FOR RESIDENTS
BRITAIN AND WHAT IS THAT EVEN
WITHOUT PLACE TO MINNESOTA THEY
SPENDING.
HALF THAT IS IT IS A SLIMMER
HELLO READERS I DON'T HAVE THEIR
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION FROM ME
TO DETERMINE REMEMBER SO WE USE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA HARD
ACCOUNT INDEX SO WE HAVE UNIQUE --
SPECIFIC INFORMATION RELATED TO
WHAT MAKES YOU HARD TO COUNT IN
CALIFORNIA AND THERE'S FOURTEEN
VARIABLES THAT GOES INTO THAT NO
WE OVERLY THOSE VERY OLD BALLS
ON OUR POPULATION TO DETERMINE
WHO IS CONSIDERED HARD ACCOUNT
WITHIN THE STATE.
AND SO WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR
FUNDING WE ARE FUNDING -- OUR
PARTNERS TO TARGET THOSE
INDIVIDUALS -- OVERALL BECAUSE
THE US CENSUS BUREAU WITH THEIR
EFFORT IS GOING FOR THE MOST
PART CAPTURE EVERYONE ELSE TO
THEIR GENERAL CAMPAIGN.
GET THIS POPULAR PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS A COMMITTEE ARMAND
FELICIANA BE OUT THE LA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS -- WE WE
SUPPORT THE CENSUS OBVIOUSLY --
STRONGLY SUPPORT IT US TO THE
QUESTION OF THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES LA COUNTY IS FACING
SOME UNIQUE CHALLENGES AND
ANTICIPATE.
I NEED ANOTHER FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO DO SENSES OUTRAGE AND
RELATED ACTIVITIES A QUICK
SNAPSHOT OF THAT OF THOSE
CHALLENGES INCLUDE.
WE'LL OVER TEN MILLION
POPULATION -- 25% LIMITED IN THE
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY AND GOOD
TWELVE THRESHOLD LANGUAGES.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
FOR LAKE COUNTY FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ON CENSUS OUT RICH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
JULIE SNYDER REPRESENTING
HOUSING CALIFORNIA ARE WE DOING
SEE POUND LAST YEAR TO PROVIDE
THE PERSPECTIVE OF CALIFORNIANS
ARE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
THOSE WHO LIVE IN NONPROFIT
DEVELOPMENTS AND THOSE WHO LIVE
IN AND STABLY HOUSE SITUATIONS
BECAUSE THEY ARE AMONG.
THE MOST HARD TO COUNT
POPULATION -- WE TODAY WHEN A
STANDARD STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
POUNDS REQUEST FOR AN ADDITIONAL
SEVEN TO SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR SPECIFICALLY
FOR C. B. R. OUTRAGE AND ANSWER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE QUESTION.
WE CAME TO THAT NUMBER BY --
DEVELOPING OUR OWN HARD TO COUNT --
ESTIMATE OF SIXTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION CALIFORNIANS -- WE SINCE
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF LOOKING AT
WHAT THE STATE HAS -- STATE
OFFICES ESTIMATED IT'S ROUGHLY
SIMILAR -- IN THEN LOOKING AT
SIMILAR OUTREACH CAMPAIGNS
AROUND THE STATE THAT VARIOUS
CBO'S HAVE PARTICIPATED IN --
AND WE CAME UP WITH THE SEVEN TO
TWELVE DOLLAR FIGURE PER PERSON
SO FAIRLY SIMPLE MATH WEEK WE
MULTIPLY THAT NUMBER TIMES A
SIXTEEN POINT TWO AND CAME UP
WITH OUR OVERALL ESTIMATE -- AND
WE SUBTRACT OUT WHAT WAS
ALLOCATED LAST YEAR -- SO.
BE TO SHARE THOSE SPECIFIC
CALCULATIONS OF THOSE NUMBERS --
WITH COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO YOU
CAN SEE HOW WE LANDED THAT THEIR
THIS MANY WOULD FIND A VARIETY
OF OUTREACH -- TYPES OF OUT
REACH EVERYTHING FROM PEOPLE
GOING SAY TO HOMELESS SHELTERS I
TO DO REGISTRATION THERE --
DOING DOOR TO DOOR CANVASSING
PHONE BANKING COMMUNITY FORUMS A
WHOLE RANGE OF ACTIVITIES THAT
WE THINK WILL INDUCE PEOPLE TO
FILL OUT THE CENSUS -- SO WE
SUPPORT HOLDING THE THE ITEM
OPEN TODAY IF YOU'RE NOT QUITE
READY TO APPROPRIATE THAT
ADDITIONAL MONEY THANK YOU.
MR TURN MEMBERS COULD EASE ALLEN
JOBBIK BUT THE GAS AND PROJECT
CALIFORNIA HERE REPRESENTING
CENSUS POLICY ADVOCACY NETWORK.
I WANTED TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE -- FROM HOUSING
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO WANT TO NOTE --
AND THAT WE SEEK ADDITIONAL
FUNDING OF SEVENTY SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS -- IT'S
URGENT -- FOR CBO IS TO GET THIS
FUNDING SO WE CAN GET THE
MESSAGE OUT AND AND DO
APPROPRIATE OUTREACH EFFORTS.
A AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- TO AND
SOME AEROBICS A WE'RE HAPPY TO
SIT DOWN WITH YOUR STAFF TO GIVE
YOU A THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF HOW
WE CAME UP WITH THAT -- DOLLAR
AMOUNT WE HAVE A TWENTY FIVE
PAGE A DEEP ANALYSIS OF THAT SO
HAPPY TO SHARE THAT WITH
EVERYONE AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
GET TO THAT ASK IT'S NOT.
WE'RE NOT POCKETING THIS MONEY
RIGHT IT'S TO MAKE SURE WE GET
THIS EFFORT RIGHT IT'S A YOU
KNOW WE HAVE ONE HERE BUDGET
YEAR LEFT.
SO WE'RE JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE STATE DOES WHAT IT
CAN -- TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHATEVER THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENT IS DOING TO UNDERMINE
THOSE EFFORTS WE SUPPLEMENT DOES
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
FOR YOUR TIME AND HAPPY TO TALK
TO ABOUT.
EVERYTHING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CENTER
CERAM SANTANA REPRESENTING
CHINESE FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
I'M YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE WANTED TO PROP POINT OUT
IN THE CENSUS OUT REACH HEARING.
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA TO PRIORITIZE THEIR
SMALLER LANGUAGE GROUPS -- THIS
IS KEY AS THEY WILL BE FOR
FURTHER MARGINALIZED WE SUPPORT
THE ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT OF
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
TRANSLATED MATERIALS BUT WE
WOULD ASK THAT -- IT MAY NOT BE
SO DEFINEDIS TRANSLATED
MATERIALS WE HAVE THREE GROUPS
THAT WE ARE PROTECT PRIORITIZING
THE PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY
WHICH IS THE LARGEST IN
CALIFORNIA OUTSIDE OF CASH --
HAWAII AND THEY HAVE ACTUALLY NO
FEDERAL LANGUAGE SUPPORTS SO
THAT WOULD MAKE THEM.
ANYTHING DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
FILL OUT THE CENSUS -- ALSO ARE
MALLER SOUTHEAST ASIAN
POPULATIONS THAT HAVE A LOWER
LITERACY RATE SO THEY MAY NEED
MATERIALS AT A LOWER LATE
LITERACY RATE.
AND MORE EMPHASIS ON A WRITTEN
INDIGENOUS LANGUAGES THEY MAY GO
BEYOND TRANSLATED MATERIALS TO
AUDIO OR ILLUSTRATIONS SO AS WE
MOVE FORWARD IN WHAT --
DETERMINES OUR OUTREACH I WOULD
ASK THAT.
THE LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN THE
STATE CENSUS OFFICE AND
LEGISLATURE REALLY PRIORITIZE
THESE GROUPS WE ALSO ASK THAT
SINCE SO HEAVILY -- REGIONAL
CBO'S AT PLANS AND STATEWIDE CBO
PLANS AND COUNTY PLANTS WILL
MAKE THE MAJORITY OF THE STATE
CENSUS OUTREACH EFFORTS THAT
THOSE PLANS ACTUALLY BE COMPILED
COMPILED SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER.
BECAUSE THIS WOULD GIVE THE
LEGISLATURE KEY STAKEHOLDERS AND
STATE CENSUS PARTNERS -- IN A
WAY TO IDENTIFY THE GAPS AND
START THAT GAP ANALYSIS SOONER.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JUDY ROBINSON
CENSUS MANAGER FOR SACRAMENTO
COUNTY -- WE WANT TO THANK THE
STATE -- FOR THE THE FUNDING
THAT WERE ALREADY GOING TO BE
RECEIVING THROUGH THE CONTRACT
ARRANGEMENT THAT WERE IN
PROCESSES OF OF IMPLEMENTING AS
WE SPEAK.
OF THE COUNTY HAS SENT A LETTER --
TO YOU ALL THAT HOPEFULLY YOU'VE
GOTTEN YOUR FILES ARE REQUESTING
AN ADDITIONAL THREE POINT NINE
MILLION IN ORDER TO WORK WITH
THE STATE AND PRIMARILY OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS SACRAMENTO COUNTY TO
ACHIEVE SUCCESS.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IS THE MOST
LINGUISTICALLY DIVERSE COUNTY IN
THE STATE AND THE FUNDING OF
THROUGH THE COUNTY AS WELL AS
OUR A CBO FOR SACRAMENTO COUNTY
IS WOEFULLY -- IT'S IT'S IT'S
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE -- THE WORK
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
WITH OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS SINCE -- LAST FALL
IS EXTREMELY DYNAMIC IT'S
GRASSROOTS AN ARM AND WERE WERE
NEEDING TO BE ABLE -- TO USE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO DO THE
NECESSARY CANVASSING WITH OUR
TRUSTED MESSENGERS TO BE IN THE
LOCATIONS AND MEET PEOPLE IN A
WHERE THEY ARE AT AGAIN IN --
MANY MANY DIFFERENT TYPES OF OF
LANGUAGES WITH DIFFERENT
COMMUNICATIONS AND DIFFERENT
MESSAGING SO -- I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS MOST OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA HAS NOT ALSO
BEEN -- SUBSIDIZED THROUGH
PRIVATE FOUNDATION FUNDING
UNLIKE OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE
SO AGAIN SOME OF THE ASSUMPTIONS
OF FUNDING THAT SCHOOLS WILL BE
RECEIVE AND OR FUNDING THAT MAY
COME FROM FOUNDATIONS.
JUST HAVE NOT MADE THEIR WAY TO
SACRAMENTO SO THANK YOU FOR A
REVIEWING -- OUR REQUEST WE HOPE
THAT YOU FIND IT WORTHY OF
FUNDING THANK YOU.
THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION FIRST
OF ALL WE WANT TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE FUNDING
ALREADY PROVIDED OR PROPOSED IN
THE JANUARY BUDGET. FOR THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY EDUCATIONAL
SECTORS THAT'S APPROXIMATELY
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS WE ARE CURRENTLY SEEKING
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN ADDITION.
IN THAT -- WE CAN PROVIDE TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR HARD TO
COUNT SCHOOLS THROUGH TWENTY
FIVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS YOU
KNOW THERE'S EIGHTY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AREA.
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ABOUT HALF OF
THAT WOULD GO TO LA U. S. D..
THE OTHER FUNDS WE WOULD NEED TO
HELP SERVE THE OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THE OTHER SEVENTY NINE
OR HOWEVER MANY MAY NEED A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
AS YOU KNOW LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION IS THE
LARGEST REGIONAL EDUCATION
AGENCY IN THE NATION MOST OTHER --
COUNTY OFFICES EDUCATION ALSO
PROVIDE REGIONAL A SERVICES TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND WE FEEL AS
THOUGH WE WOULD BE THE BEST
PLACE TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORTS AN OUT
REACH. TO SCHOOLS WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE COME TO SCHOOLS PARENTS
AND CHILDREN FEEL SAFE WHEN THEY
COME TO SCHOOLS AND THIS IS THE
MOST LOGICAL PLACE TO PUT
RESOURCES SO THAT WE CAN DO OF
THE MOST APPROPRIATE COUNCIL WE
HAVE FOCUSED ON HARD TO COUNT.
TITLE ONE SCHOOLS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
PROVIDING MORE SYSTEMS ARE FOR
OUR LETTERS ON FILE WITH YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JENNIFER APPEARING HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
TEN THOUSAND POLICY SORRY TEN
THOUSAND MEMBER POLICY ALLIANCE
WERE PLEASE BE FOUNDING
ORGANIZATION ASSOCIATED WITH
WITH C. PAN AND ONE ALIGN MY
REMARKS OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO
HAVE.
ARTICULATED ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE INADEQUACY OF THE FUNDS THAT
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED SO FAR FOR
CBO OUT WE CAN I THINK.
I THINK AT THE NUMBER OF OF THE
ISSUE IS CBO CERTAIN AND
NONPROFITS IN CALIFORNIA ARE ALL
IN -- TO HELP MAKE SURE THAT THE
CENSUS COUNT IS DONE IN THE MOST
ROBUST AND EFFECTIVE WAY THAT
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK WE HAVE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION ABOUT HOW
MUCH IT WILL A COST.
THOSE CBA'S TO CBO'S TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THAT AND HOW
WHAT'S THE BRIDGE THE ALLOCATION
OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT.
THAT'S GIVEN TO CBO IS TO DO
THIS WORK AND WE DO FEEL THAT WE
HAVE A UNIQUE RELATIONSHIP WITH
OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO BE A VITAL
PARTNER.
IN REACHING HARD TO COUNT
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA AND ARE
DEEPLY CONCERNED THAT WILL GET
INTO THIS AND NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES WE NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND NOT HAVE A BACK
UP PLAN -- FOR ORGANIZATIONS
THAT WHOSE COMMITMENT WILL BE
UNWAVERING BUT THE RESOURCES TO
BE SUCCESSFUL BE LIMITED SO WE
THANK YOU MISTER TRUMAN AS WAX
FOR ASKING THAT WE EXTEND THIS
CONVERSATION I WANT TO BE AS
HELPFUL AS WE CAN GIVING THAT
ANALYTICS DRIVING AREN'T
UNDERPINNING OUR ESTIMATE.
THANK YOU A QUESTION FOR YOU SO
WHAT IS YOUR ESTIMATE ON THE
COST WHAT IT SHOULD BE.
WELL I ACTUALLY WANT TO JUST. TO
LOOK MORE CLOSELY IF WE'RE USING
A SIMILAR NUMBER OF SIXTEEN ASH
SIXTEEN POINT TWO MILLION HARD
TO COUNT CALIFORNIANS AND WE'RE
SAYING IT'S SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
SEVEN AND TWELVE DOLLARS AND THE
STATE THE GOVERNOR'S.
FOLKS ARE SAYING IT'S NINE AND
TEN THEN THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT INCLUDED IN THE TOTAL
OR THE IS THE MEDIA OUR REACH
INCLUDED IN A IN A DIFFERENT
BUCKET I'M NOT SURE.
THE QUESTION IS THE ALLOCATION
OF WORKLOAD HERE AND WHAT THE
RIGHT NUMBER FOR CBO IS INVOLVED
IN THIS.
EFFORT WOULD BE WELL IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN WAS THE FIVE
MILLION ON THE CENSUS RIGHT NOW
AT A HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN
MILLION.
FOODS AND EVERYBODY IN HERE SOME
FOLKS WOULD BE AT THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
SO THINGS ARE CHANGING
WASHINGTON CRIME IS DIFFERENT.
YOU NEED MORE BUT THAT'S A BIG
BIG DIFFERENCE SO I DO NOT
DISAGREE WITH USER YES WE'RE
TRYING TO BE VERY CAUTIOUS IN
HOW WE APPROACH THIS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON NO F. ITEM WITH
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
WHERE AN ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
WE SERVE FARMWORKERS AND I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT PRIORITIZING ARE
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
COMMITTEES PARTICULIER
INDIGENOUS FARMWORKER
COMMUNITIES? 30% OF OUR
FARMWORKERS ARE INDIGENOUS TO
SPEAK A LANGUAGE OTHER THAN
SPANISH MYSTICAL A TRICKY.
AND THERE'S ANOTHER -- LANGUAGE
BLOCKING YELLS AND THEY HAVE
THEIR UNIQUE CHALLENGES THESE
ARE NON WRITTEN AS WAS BEEN
TESTIFIED BEFORE WHEN MAKE SURE
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES ARE
ALLOCATED TO THESE COMMUNITIES.
THEY THETHEY HAVE THESE NEEDS
AND ALSO TIED THE MEDIA ASPECT
BECAUSE THEY WORK WITH MEDIA AND
THAT'S A KEY PART AND MAKE SURE
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES
ADDRESS THERE.
NOW.
THE LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN IS
SUPPOSED TO BE RELEASED AS WAS
INFORMED AT THE INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON MAY SEVENTEENTH.
HOWEVER WE DO NOT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON THAT
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN WE WOULD
SUPPORT.
A COMMENT PERIOD.
THAT'S REASONABLE SO WE CAN LOOK
AT IT PARTICULARLY SINCE OUR
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITY.
IS IN DANGER OF BEING LEFT OUT
OF A ROBUST LANGUAGE ACCESS
PLANTS WE MAKE SURE THAT'S
INCLUDED.
WE ALSO STAND IN SUPPORT WITH A
C. PAN IN TERMS OF THE BUDGET
ASK WE APPRECIATE THIS ITEM
BEING HELD OPEN SO WE CAN REALLY.
LOOK AT WHAT TYPE OF FUNDING IS
NEEDED TO BE ADDRESSED.
PARTICULARLY IN THIS TIME THAT'S
THE CHAIR HAS.
REFERRED AND THE OTHER COMMENTS
AS WELL BY THE MEMBERS OF THE
DANGEROUS CLIMATE THAT ARE
IMMIGRANT COMMUTERS ARE FACING
THROUGH FEAR INTIMIDATION AND
COERCION MORE RECENTLY AS WHAT
WHAT DONE WITH THE PUBLIC CHARGE
ISSUE OVER THE WEEKEND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IF YOU'RE NOT I MEAN IT'S NOT TO
KNOW WHAT CHILDREN NOW WE'RE
ALSO A NUMBER OF C. PAN AND
CHILDREN NOW'S INTEREST AND AND
FOR OUR PARTNERS FIRST.
FIVE ASSOCIATION WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT ENSURING THAT
COMMUNITIES KNOW THAT THEY NEED
TO COUNT THEIR INFANTS AND THEIR
BABIES -- OVER.
HE LARGE NUMBER OF CHILDREN AND
INFANTS WERE NOT COUNTED AND WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S A OT AT RISK --
BUT I THINK WE WANT TO ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS OF OUR PARTNERS AT C.
POUND WHAT'S AT STAKE -- FOR THE
STATE IS IS.
MASSIVE AND MAKING SURE THAT ALL
SIXTEEN POINT TWO OF OUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE PART OF
THE THE HARD TO COUNT.
POPULATIONS ARE.
PROPERLY OUT REACH TO BY TRUSTED
MESSENGERS MULTIPLE HEADS
MULTIPLE DOOR KNOBS ON THE WE
DISPEL SOME OF THOSE MIXED
MESSAGES WHEN FOLKS WERE TELLING
FOLKS NOT TO OPEN THE DOOR FOR
ICE BUT WE'RE THàNH PHùTO
OPEN THE DOOR FOR NUMERATOR SO I
THINK.
THERE'S A REAL VALID CONCERN FOR
MAKE STATUS COMMUNITIES I'M FOR
LIMITED ENGLISH COMMITTEES AND
WE KNOW THAT TRUSTED MESSENGERS
NONPROFIT OUT REACH IS THE WAY
THAT THAT MANY OF OUR FOLKS GET
THEIR EDUCATION AWARENESS AND
ENSURE THAT THEY CAN TRUST OUR
GOVERNMENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BECAUSE THE RESPONSE OF THE
CHAIR THAT THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION WE'VE TAKEN
AFFIRMATIVE STANCE TO ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE.
COUNTED IN THE C. R. TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS -- WE JUST
LAUNCHED OUR CAMPAIGN ALL GOING
ON LOCAL DEALERS OUT TO MAKE
SURE EVERYONE IS COUNTED AND
AREAS OF ORANGE COUNTY LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SACRAMENTO COUNTY
THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
ON CLEANING FRESNO AND OTHER
ROLE PARTS OF CALIFORNIA I THINK
AS YOU MENTIONED SURE THAT -- IT
IS GOING TO BE A CHALLENGING
YEAR -- BUT NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF
THE FEDERAL LAW POLICIES BUT
ALSO BECAUSE OF MAYBE POSSIBLE --
SUPPRESSION ENGAGE IN CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT FOR THE CENSUS AS WE
SEEN HAPPEN IN -- TWENTY TEN SO
FOR THOSE REASONS ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM C. PAN -- WE
WOULD REQUEST TO HAVE OPEN.
THANK YOU.
OBVIOUSLY SINCE QUESTION IS IS
IS HARD I FED LEVY TOSSED A WITH
MR CHIU AND AND THIS WEEK ABOUT --
THE ISSUE -- WE TALK STAFF ABOUT
IT AT LENGTH -- THERE'S CONCERN
ABOUT UNDER COUNT AS A REAL
POSSIBILITY.
A WITH THAT WE'RE TRYING TO AS
MUCH AS WE CAN TO ENSURE THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS ACCOUNT
REPRESENTED.
IN THE CENSUS SO WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO BALANCE THAT WITH
OLYMPIC.
SINCE THE STAFF AGAINST HOUSING
STAFF SO A LOT OF MOVING PARTS
THERE'S A FINITE NUMBER OF
DOLLARS HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE
GOT A LOT OF ISSUES TO DEAL WITH.
THE GOVERNOR SOME VERY AMBITIOUS
PLANS -- A LOT OF BALLS IN THE
AIR SO YOU'LL SEE WHERE IT GOES
FROM HERE SO.
AFTER MUCH DELIBERATION HOLES
ITEM OPEN AND HAVE FOR
DISCUSSIONS.
SOMEONE LESS ITEM WHICH IS ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SO NO DEVELOPMENT
CENTER CLOSURE
[inaudible]
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT HI MY NAME IS JASON
KENNEY I AM THE DIRECTOR FOR
REAL ESTATE SERVICES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES --
THE CINEMA DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF YOU
REPRESENTS YEARS OF WORK TO GET
TO THIS POINT ALL PROVIDE A
QUICK OVERVIEW OF PROPOSAL.
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE -- THE PROPOSAL SIX FORTY
THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS TO
MAINTAIN A NINE HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE ACRE CAMPUS IN CINEMA.
AND SUCCESSFULLY DISPOSE OF THE
PROPERTY IN A WAY THAT BENEFITS
THE STATE AND SUPPORTS LOCAL
COMMUNITY IN WHICH IS PROPERTY
SETS THE CAMPUS.
THE OLDEST OF THE DON'T KNOW
CENTERS -- FIRST BEGAN IN
EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE IT HAS ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY ACRES OF DEVELOP
SITE WITH OVER A HUNDRED TWENTY
BILLION BUILDINGS AFTER HAVING
BEEN DEVASTATED BY THE NUNS FIRE
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN LOSING ABOUT
TWENTY STRUCTURES --
HISTORICALLY HAD THE MANAGED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND IS BEYOND ITS
USEFUL LIFE.
OTHER POLLS WILL SEEKS FUNDING
IN TWO BASIC AREAS -- ONE TO
COVER THREE YEARS OF MAINTENANCE
COSTS WHICH WILL PRIMARILY BE
PROVIDED VIA CONTRACT TO DDS TO
CONTINUE THEIR OVERSIGHT OF THE
PROPERTY -- DDS HAS RUN THE
FACILITY FOR DECADES AND AS
MAINTAIN THE PROPERTY CAN SHUT
DOWN SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DECEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHEN
THE LAST RESIDENT LEFT THE
CENTER.
THESE CALLS REFLECTIVE REDUCTION
IN DDS A STAFFING OVER THE LAST
SIX MONTHS TO MORE COST
EFFECTIVELY MANAGE THE PROPERTY.
IN ADDITION THE PROPERTY MUST BE
REZONED IN ORDER TO SUCCESSFULLY
DISPOSED THE PROPERTY IN A WAY
THAT BENEFITS THE STATE AND THE
COMMUNITY -- TO REDUCE THE STATE
COSTS AND LIABILITY FOR THE
CAMPUS AND TO INCREASE THE VALUE
OF THE PROPERTY AS WELL AS
INSURER I COMMITTEE INTEGRATION
PROPOSAL SEEKS FUNDING TO THE
COUNTY TO CONDUCT AN EXPEDITED
SPECIFIC PLAN AND RESUME THE
SITE.
OF THE COST FOR THE X. BUT A
PROCESS IS THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH WILL CUT
THE COUNTIES INITIAL TIME BY
MORE THAN HALF I WILL SAY THE
STATE APPROXIMATE FORTY IGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN AVOIDED
MAINTENANCE COSTS.
THE PROPOSAL REPRESENTS THE FOR
NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN THE STATE
THE COMMUNITY INCLUDING LOCAL
OFFICIALS AND MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE UP IN THE AREA
INCLUDING SENATOR DODD SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ULTIMATELY THIS PROPOSAL MIRRORS
THE AUTHORITY GRANTED TO THE
STATE AND THE TRADITIONAL
SURPLUS PROCESS -- TO DISPOSE OF
THE PROPERTY HOWEVER THE MAIN
DIFFERENCE IS THE EXPEDITED US
SPECIFIC PLAN PROCESS WHICH WILL
SAVE THE STATE MONEY AND
SAFEGUARD THE FUTURE USE THE
PROPERTY IN COMMUNITY INTERESTS.
OF THE THE PROPOSAL ALSO HAS THE
SUPPORT OF THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WHICH PASSED A
RESOLUTION APRIL FIFTH
SUPPORTING THE CONCEPT AND
AGREEING TO TO BEGIN WORK ON THE
EXPANDED PLAN -- AND REZONING IN
THIS CURRENT YEAR.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
LA UP.
HIKERS YOU AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE -- I APOLOGIZE
WE DIDN'T GET OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS OUT VERY FAR IN
ADVANCE ON THIS -- ONE AS I KIND
OF LIKE BREAKING PROPOSAL FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION WE ACTUALLY
HAVE.
FIVE SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS ON
THIS PROPOSAL THE FIRST IS TO
LIMIT THE FUNDING TO YOU JUST
NINETEEN TWENTY SO AS WAS
MENTIONED BY THE DEPARTMENT
THEY'RE PROPOSING -- PROVIDING
THREE YEARS OF FUNDING -- WE
SUGGEST WHEN YOU'RE FINDING
BECAUSE WE THINK THERE'S
SIGNIFICANT UNCERTAINTY
REGARDING -- THE FUNDING LEVELS
THAT WILL BE REQUIRED FOR THIS
WARM SHUT DOWN PERIOD AND
MAINTENANCE THE PROPERTY
PARTICULARLY IN THE OUT YEARS
ADDITIONALLY A PROVIDING JUST
WHEN YOU'RE FINDING WILL PROVIDE
THE LEGISLATURE WITH ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATION COME BACK NEXT
YEAR REPORT ON WHERE IT IS HOW
THE PROCESS.
IS WORKING -- AND WHAT FUNDING
THEY NEED.
SO I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WE'RE ALSO PROPOSING --
AS WAS MENTIONED -- THERE'S A
FUNDING PROVIDED TO THAT COUNTY
OF SO NO MY TO DO A LOCAL
PLANNING PROCESS THIS IS PERHAPS
PRETTY UNUSUAL -- WE'RE
RECOMMENDING THAT -- THIS CINEMA
COUNTY BE REQUIRED TO SEEK
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THIS FUNDING
RATHER THAN HAVING THE FUNDING
PROVIDED UP FRONT -- PART OF
THIS IS BECAUSE IT IS SUCH A
UNIQUE THING FOR US TO BE PAYING
FOR THESE KINDS OF COST WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE WITH
HOW MUCH THEY SHOULD BE.
AND THREE POINT FIVE MILLION IS
IS A SIGNIFICANT OUT OF FUNDING.
THE THIRD RECOMMENDATION IS TO
MODIFY THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO REFLECT THE LEGISLATURE'S
GOALS SO WHAT WILL AS WAS
REFERENCE THERE'S TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT ACCOMPANIES THIS
PROPOSAL.
IT ESTABLISHES A PROCESS FOR
DISPOSING OF THIS PROPERTY
THAT'S DIFFERENT FROM THE
TRADITIONAL SURPLUS PROPERTY
PROCESS IN SOME WAYS IT'S
SIMILAR -- BUT ACTUALLY PROVIDES
EVEN BROADER AUTHORITY TO THE
DEAD DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
A PROVIDE SOME VERY BROAD GOALS --
BUT NOT MUCH IN TERMS OF
SPECIFICITY -- AND IT THE
TRADITIONAL PROCESS HAVE KIND OF
A LOADING ORDER OF THINGS THAT
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED AND THAT'S
ABSENT HERE -- SO WE THINK THAT
IF THE LEGISLATURE HAS SPECIFIC
GOALS THINGS LIKE -- ITS GOALS
FOR ACHIEVING -- CERTAIN
OUTCOMES FOR THE DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED COMMUNITY OR FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT THESE
COULD BE MADE MORE CLEAR.
I WE ALSO SUGGEST -- FOURTH THAT
THE TRAILER BILL BE AMENDED TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT.
THIS COULD BE DONE FOR EXAMPLE
BY REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT TO
COME BACK WITH A NOTIFICATION
PRIOR TO THE SALE OR A MONTH
FROM THE PROPERTY.
AND THEN THE FIFTH
RECOMMENDATION IS JUST TO
CONSIDER WHETHER THE
LEGISLATURE'S COMFORTABLE WITH --
THE POTENTIAL PRESIDENT THAT
THIS COULD SAT I SO THIS
PROPERTY IS QUITE UNIQUE WHICH
IS ONE OF THE REASONS THE
DEPARTMENT IS COMFORTABLE WITH
TAKING THIS APPROACH -- BUT THIS
IS AN UNUSUAL APPROACH JUST THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S INVOLVED
IS UNUSUAL PLAYING PAYING FOR
THESE LOCAL PLANNING COST IS
UNUSUAL AND ALSO -- THE PROCESS
IT'S ENVISIONED IN THAT TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE I SAID CERTAINLY
OTHER COMMUNITIES COULD COULD
MAKE SIMILAR ASKS IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
WITH THE PROPER TRANSITION THE
D. G. S. WAS THE MOST LIKELY
FINAL USABLE AND IT WILL DEPEND
ALTERNATELY ON WHAT THE FINAL
REZONING IS -- WE DO AND IT IS A
PAID COMMERCIAL USE -- AS WELL
AS HOUSING BOTH -- MARKET AND
AFFORDABLE -- THERE WILL BE
OTHER LOCALIZED PACIFIC USES
THERE IS A CEMETERY ON CAMPUS
AND SO THAT WERE MAIN AS SUCH --
THEY'RE LIKELY BE MUSEUM --
THEY'VE BEEN A NUMBER OF OTHER
EXPRESSED COMMUNITY -- PROPOSALS
AS WELL MOST OF THE CAMPUS IS
CURRENTLY OPEN SPACE AND THAT
WILL REMAIN -- IF THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE IS IS IS PUT
FORWARD -- THIS ABOUT NINE
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE ACRES IN THE
CAMPUS IN TOTAL AND
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY PLUS OR MINUS ARE OPEN
SPACE SO REMAIN.
FORCE THAT AREA.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE.
GROWING UP IN A PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CAROLING ABOUT THIS AND
ON THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HERE WITH ART WHEN
THE STRONGER SUPPORT FOR THIS
PROPOSAL THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
I HEARD HAD A SPECIAL HEARING
THIS DIALECT IT'S CAME DID YES
CAME IN APRIL AND WHAT THEY
DISCUSSED THIS IN A PUBLIC
SETTING -- IT'S IT'S JUST A
COUPLE PAGES IN FRONT OF YOU
IT'S FOUR YEARS OF WORK FOUR
YEARS OF MEETINGS AND CONFERENCE
CALLS AND INCLUSION AND OF THE
PUBLIC PROCESS TO GET TO THIS.
A PROPOSAL DID YES HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY PATIENT AND THE BOARD
OR JUST YOUR APPROVAL OF THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION TODAY TO
MOVE IT FORWARD.
THEY ARE VERY CLEAR THAT HOUSING
NEEDS TO BE PART OF THIS THERE
NEEDS TO BE A GOOD PLAN IN PLACE
THAT WILL HELP TGI SELL IT FOR
THE HIGHEST VALUE.
OF WHAT THE STATE DOES ABOUT
MONEY AFTER IT SOLD IS YOUR
BUSINESS -- BUT HELPING THE
COMMUNITY HAVE A ROLE IN IT
WHICH THIS -- PROPOSAL BEFORE
YOU PROVIDES AND WE'LL WE'LL GET
THEM TO PLACE FASTER THE HOUSES
OWNING PLAN THAT IS GOING TO
ACTUALLY HAVE THE SUPPORT OF THE
COMMUNITY SO WE URGE YOUR
APPROVAL TODAY AND THINK YOU CAN
TO THE TGS FOR ALL OF YOUR
PATIENTS AND I EASIER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE RECOGNITION SADAT THE SPRING%
FISCAL LETTER WITH BUDGET BILL
REPORTING LANGUAGE.
OUR MOTION. FOR THE MOTION
SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE.
COOPER HI [inaudible]
TWO LACKEY NAZARIAN [inaudible]
WICKS HI.
WAS THIS IS ITEM NUMBER -- EIGHT
IMMIGRATION HUMAN TRAFFICKING
RAPID RESPONSE PROGRAM
.
SENATE HAMAD APARTMENT A FINANCE
THE GENDER NICELY LAYS OUT THE
PROPOSAL FOR YOU SOME HAPPY TO
RIDE AT A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS REQUESTING
TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND AND TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
FOUR THE IMMIGRATION HUMAN
TRAFFICKING RAPID RESPONSE
RESERVE.
THE INTENT OF THE RESERVISTS TO
BE FLEXIBLE IN ORDER TO MEET
FUTURE EMERGENT SITUATIONS FOR
GRAIN EMIGRATION HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES RESERVE
IT IS AS IS CURRENTLY PROPOSES
MUST TIME EFFICIENT MECHANISM TO
RESPOND TO EMERGENCY SITUATION
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT WE
MAY NOT KNOW WHICH STATE AGENCY.
IS WOULD BE THE MOST APPROPRIATE
TO RESPOND TO WHAT THE SITUATION
WHAT MAY BE.
RECOGNIZE THERE ARE SOME
pPROPOSED MORE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
HAVING CONVERSATIONS AND PROVIDE
A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
PROPOSED LANGUAGE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NO COMMENT KAMALA ALL RIGHT.
OKAY SIR ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS.
GREAT -- IS THE MOTION IS TO
MOVE FUNDING FOR THIS ACTIVITY
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND IT UP THE BUDGET
BILLING WHICH IS THEIR MOTION
[inaudible]
SECOND [inaudible]
NUMBER.
ONE SO NOW WE HAVE A CORD
[inaudible]
NOW THIS [inaudible]
LOCAL POLICE.
COOPER HI.
TO LACKEY MISSOURIAN
[inaudible] SIX WHICH IS TO SAY
NEVER NINE THINGS WAS REVENUE
OPPORTUNITY SYSTEM [inaudible]
SOMETHING.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
KATIE HAGEN CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY AS YOU KNOW
SEE THE TFA WAS BORN IN JULY OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
ASSUME DAHLE THE STATUTORY
DUTIES.
PREVIOUSLY HELD BY THE STATE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION ACCEPTED
THE PALETTE FUNCTION.
STANDING UP THIS NEW DEPARTMENT
HAS BEEN BOTH CHALLENGING AND
EXCITING.
AND I AM PROUD OF WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS THE DEPARTMENT
PRIMARILY HAS FOCUSED ON
ADDRESSING ALL FINDINGS FROM THE
STATE COMPTROLLER.
THE STATE PERSONNEL BOARD AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AUDITS.
IMPROVING EMPLOYEE ENGAGEMENT
AND MORALE MAKING SURE THAT OUR
TAX ADMINISTRATION IS CONSISTENT
AND EFFICIENT ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SUCCESSFULLY STANDING UP
CROSS OUR AUTOMATED SYSTEM TO
REPLACE OUR AGE TO LEGACY
SYSTEMS.
AT THIS POINT WE'VE CLOSED OUT
APPROXIMATELY 42% OF THE FIFTY
NINE EXTERNAL AUDIT FINDINGS AND
WE ARE ACTIVELY WORKING TO CLOSE
THE REMAINDER.
WE'VE ESTABLISHEDA DIVERSITY
AND INCLUSION PROGRAM REINSTATED
AN EMPLOYEE MENTORING PROGRAM.
CREATED A TRAINING IN INTERNAL
AUDIT PROGRAM FOR MERIT BASED
HIRING PRACTICES AND DEVELOPED
AN ANTI NEPOTISM POLICY AND
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS TO
ADDRESS NEPOTISM IN THE
DEPARTMENT.
AMONG MANY OTHER THINGS.
WE ALSO HAVE RESTRUCTURED OUR
FIELD OPERATIONS TEAM AND
REVISED REVISED PROCEDURES TO
FURTHER CONSISTENT TAX
ADMINISTRATION.
AND WE CONTINUE WORKING TO
IMPROVE THE TAXPAYER EXPERIENCE
BY REDUCING PROCESSING TIMES.
FOR EXAMPLE RUBRIC WE REDUCE THE
TIME IT TAKES FOR CD TFA TO
PROCESS AN OFFER IN COMPROMISE
OF A TAXPAYERS TAX LIABILITY.
FROM NINE MONTHS TO THIRTY DAYS.
FINALLY ALTHOUGH WE HAVE HAD
SOME CHALLENGES ALONG THE WAY
OUR CROSS PROJECT IS ON TIME AND
ON BUDGET AND IT WORKS AS IT
SHOULD.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
IMPROVEMENTS BY IMPLEMENTING OUR
STRATEGIC AND BUSINESS PLAN
INITIATIVES AND WOULD BE HAPPY
TO SIT DOWN WITH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO DISCUSS OUR PLANS IN
FURTHER DETAIL.
AT YOUR CONVENIENCE.
TURNING TO OUR FIRST OF FIVE BC
PLEASE AND PLEASE INTERRUPT ME
IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS OF COURSE
WE HAVE A FEW -- THE FIRST AT WE
HAVE LISTED IS THE US CENTRALIZE
REVENUE OPPORTUNITY SYSTEM OR
CROSS PROJECT.
THIS IS OUR REVENUE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM APPROVED IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN DESIGNED TO
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY AND
EFFECTIVENESS.
OF C. D. T. OCT CD TFA IS
OPERATIONS EXPAND TAX AND FEE
PAYER SERVICES.
AND ENHANCE ITS ABILITY TO
GENERATE INCREASED REVENUES.
ON MAY 200-072-00018 SKEWS ME
CROSS WENT LIVE FOR SALES AND
USE TAX WHICH REPRESENTS
APPROXIMATELY 85% OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S REVENUE.
THE CITY TFA IS REQUESTING
TWENTY FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
TO CONTINUE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE CROSS PROJECT IN FISCAL YEAR.
NINETEEN TWENTY THE FUNDS
REQUESTED WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE TESTING
AND ENHANCEMENTS AHEAD OF
ROLLOUTS THREE AND FOUR FOR
SPECIAL TAXES AND FEES.
ANY QUESTIONS ON MATTER I CAN GO
ON TO THE NEXT [inaudible]
FINANCE.
BRIAN ROADS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THESE ARE CRITICAL
RESOURCES FOR A PROJECT THAT'S
ON TRACK.
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
THE CAESAREAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I'M
ASSUMING NEXT ITEM BEING.
ITEM NUMBER.
TWELVE WHEN YOU SEND MOVING OUT
THE NEXT ITEM.
I BELIEVE SO IS THAT OKAY ANIMUS
THAN THAN OKAY THEN LET ME LET
ME TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY AS A
QUICK QUESTION.
SEVEN NEVER SPECIFIC SHINS OR OR
WORSE WAS ON NINE HUNDRED AYE
MISSIONS AREA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'LL HOLD MY QUESTION THAT OKAY.
MULTIPLE COLORS ITEM.
OKAY CONVOLUTION PLEASE.
SO WHAT WAS BUDGET SECOND.
WILL HELP COOPER HI.
TWO LACKEY.
IS THERE AN HI WICKS.
CASE NUMBER TEN ACCOUNTING
BRIDGE POSITIONS AUGMENTATION.
ALL RIGHT.
IF THINGS -- TO TEN SO AT THE
ACCOUNTING FRANCE POSITIONS
AUGMENTATION -- THIS IS OUR AT
THE C. P. TO ADDRESS VARIOUS
AUDIT FINDINGS -- AS WELL AS
OTHER CRITICAL AND MET WORKLOAD
NEEDS -- AT A RELATED TO BOTH
FISTS CAL AND CROSS
IMPLEMENTATION -- WE CONDUCTED
AN INTERNAL ANALYSIS INDICATING
THAT WE NEEDED TEN ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS IN OUR ACCOUNTING AREA.
OF THE TEN POSITIONS FIVE WERE
REDIRECTED FROM OTHER AREAS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
IDENTIFIED BUT WE ARE RESTRICTED
FROM REDIRECTING THOSE BECAUSE
THEY ARE CATEGORIZED AS
PROVISION.
ONE OR REVENUE PRODUCING --
POSITIONS -- AS DAVE DESIGNATED
IN PROVISION ONE AS A RESULTS WE
REQUEST FINANCE APPROVAL -- TO
AND LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL TO RE
DIRECT.
OF FIVE VACANT PROVISION ONE
POSITIONS IN HOUSE AND PROVIDE A
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION IN THE BUDGET AND
I'M GOING TO FUND THE SALARY
DIFFERENCE FOR THOSE POSITIONS
[inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
LL.
SEC CHRISTINE LA ERA AS NOTED IN
THE STAFF COMMON IN THE AGENDA
THE NECESSITY OF THIS REQUEST
COMES FROM A PROVISION ONE OF
THE BUDGET ACT WHICH APPLIES --
TO THE THREE A TAXIDERMIST
MINISTRATION AGENCIES AND THIS
IS AN EXAMPLE OF SERVE A TRADE
OFF THAT IT'S ARISES FROM
INCLUDING THIS PROVISION IN THE
BUDGET ACT IT.
PROVIDES SOME BUDGET CONTROLLING
OVERSIGHT BUT AT THE SAME TIME
REDUCES DEPARTMENTS FLEXIBILITY
AND EFFICIENCY -- GIVEN THE
STRAIGHT OFF WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE RECONSIDER
WHETHER THIS LONG STANDING
PROVISION IS WARRANTED.
THANK YOU.
AT THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
APPROVE OF A SORRY EXCUSE ME --
FOR SOME OF THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS THE ONE I HAD A QUESTION.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU STEP OUT FOR A MINUTE.
THANK YOU AND I THINK AND AND
THE LA -- SPOKE TO IT -- ALSO I
I WANTED.
TO I GUESS JUST KIND OF GET A
SENSE OF ARE THERE ANY BRANCHES
WITHIN THE CITY TFA OUTSIDE OF
THE ACCOUNTING BENCH THAT ARE.
HAVING DIFFICULTY GIVEN THE
PROVISION OF PROVISION
[inaudible]
ONE RESTRAINTS -- THAT THE SHORT
ANSWER WOULD BE YES -- THE
DIRECTOR MADURO'S AND I WERE
BOTH HIRED AT NEW TO THIS NEW
DEPARTMENT A YEAR AND A HALF TWO
YEARS AGO.
AND WE'VE BEEN DOING OUR LEVEL
BEST TO READ OR RE DIRECT
RESOURCES FROM WITHIN RATHER
THAN COME -- TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND FINANCE WITH LARGE ASKS --
AND WE'RE ABLE TO DO THAT IN
MANY ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT
FUNCTIONS -- BUT A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF OUR DEPARTMENT --
HAVE -- COLLECTIONS AN AUDITING
STAFF THAT ARE DESIGNATED
PROVISION -- ONE MORE THAN HALF
OF THE ENTERPRISE AND SO IT
MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT TO MOVE
POSITIONS AROUND BECAUSE BECAUSE
OF THAT DESIGNATION -- ONE OF
THE THINGS WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING
WITH LA -- AND FINANCES POSSIBLY --
JUST CHANGING THE DEFINITION OF
WHAT PROVISION ONE IS IF IF
THERE ISN'T A DESIRE TO DO AWAY
WITH IT COMPLETELY.
PERHAPS JUST REDEFINE IT TO GIVE
US SOME FLEXIBILITY TO MOVE
POSITIONS AROUND AND WE WOULD BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO REPORT.
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS OR WHATEVER --
APPROPRIATE TIME FRAME TO THE
LEGISLATURE SO YOU HAVE A WINDOW
INTO -- THE CHANGES THAT WERE
MAKING.
AND I JUST SAID -- A LOT OF THE
EXTERNAL REVIEWS FOCUSED ON SOME
WEAKNESSES IN ACCOUNTING AND SO
THAT'S WHERE OUR PAIN IS IS MOST
SEVERE WHICH IS WHY WE'RE ASKING
FOR ACCOUNTING SPECIFICALLY HERE.
WE SO WEAKNESSES IN THE
ACCOUNTING.
YES SO -- AS AS KATIE MENTIONED --
TO OUR DEPARTMENT WAS FOUNDED
JUST TWO YEARS AGO AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN IN PART AS A RESULT OF
VARIOUS EXTERNAL REVIEWS ON THE
CONTROLLER -- SAY DID YOU ASK
TRUCK -- AND SO A LOT OF THOSE
REVIEWS FOCUSED ON WEAKNESSES IN
ACCOUNTING SO FOR IS A ARNOLD
CONTROL MA'AM FOR FOR EXAMPLE --
THERE IS A ONE TIME FEE OVER
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR --
BASICALLY REALLOCATION OUR SALES
TAX FUND -- AND THERE ARE SOME
OTHER GAPS THAT WERE THAT WERE
WORKING TO FILL A MEDICINE YOUR
LEVEL WE'VE RESTRUCTURED I'M OUR
DIVISION AND SEE A ROLES -- TO
FOCUS MORE ON ACCOUNTING AND ON
OPERATIONS AND THE SASS FOCUSES
MORE ON THE STAFF LEVEL --
PERSONNEL TO REALLY IMPLEMENT
SOME OF THESE CONTROLS.
CHECK THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANKS.
ONGOING OPEN UP PUBLIC COMMENT.
THIS RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE
HIS BUDGET BUT I ALSO LIKE TO
DIRECT STAFF TO WORK WITH DEAL
F..
L. A. L. I. MODIFY PROVISION ONE
FOR CITY TFA AN F. T. B..
THE OTHER BRING BACK LANGUAGE
OUT FOR THE MAY REVISE.
THANKS AS GOOD AS OUR MOTION.
SEVEN FIVE SIR SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
TO LACKEY.
NAZARIAN HI WICKS. SIX IS TO
ISSUE ELEVEN IMPLEMENTATION THE
CANVAS TAX REGULATIONS.
ALRIGHT SO -- THE ETEXT PAIRED --
TRANSPARENT.
TRANSPARENCY AND FAIRNESS ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ESTABLISH
THE CD TFA TO PERFORM MANDATED
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CONTROL --
AND REGULATE AND TAX ADULT USE
OF MARIJUANA ACT PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR AND THE BUSINESS ROLE
AN ADULT USE CANNABIS REGULATION
AND SAFETY ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN CD TFA HASN'T
ENFORCEMENT ROLE IN THE CANNABIS
TAX PROGRAM -- BUT HAS BEEN
UNABLE TO COMMENCE ENFORCEMENT
OF LICENSING AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WITH CURRENT
RESOURCES.
CD TFA REQUEST TWO POINT NINE
MILLION AND THIRTEEN POINT NINE
POSITIONS IN FISCAL YEAR.
NINETEEN TWENTY WITH THE
APPROVAL THE REQUESTED ESOURCES
THE CD TFA COULD BEGIN
ADDRESSING NON COMPLIANCE ISSUES
RESULTING IN ANTICIPATED
ADDITIONAL REVENUE FOR THE STATE.
AND I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT UP TO THIS POINT -- WE'VE
ARE WE HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY
ENGAGING ON EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH OF OUR TAXPAYERS -- AND
THIS VCP IS SPECIFICALLY FOR
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES
[inaudible]
L. L..
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS.
FINANCE.
PROVIDING ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES
WILL ACHIEVE THE BROADER GOAL OF
HELPING FORMALIZE THE INDUSTRY.
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE COMMITTEE.
OPEN UP PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
ITEM -- CAN SEE TSA QUICK
QUESTION FOR MR LACKEY.
YEAH ON THIS PARTICULAR MEASURE
IS ANY THIS FUNDING OR ANY THESE
POSITIONS FOCUSED ON GOING AFTER
A LIST OF MARKET PLAYERS OR IS
THIS JUST ALL THOSE WHO ARE
TRYING TO COMPLY AND LICENSING.
NO YET YOUR YES THERE ARE --
THAT THESE RESOURCES ARE FOR
ENFORCEMENT SO -- AS I INDICATED
THAT -- OUR EFFORTS TO DATE HAVE
BEEN ON EDUCATION AND OUTREACH --
AND WE'RE NOT WORRIED ABOUT THE
FOLKS THAT ARE FILING YOUR TAXES
THAT WE'RE GOING AFTER WITH THIS
P. C. P. WE WILL BE TARGETING
THOSE THEY'RE NOT COMPLIANT --
GOING AFTER -- DISTRIBUTORS --
RETAIL SALES SHOPS THERE'S AND A
WHOLE NUMBER OF UNDERGROUND AND
CONNIE WITH THOSE I I'M JUST
TRYING TO SAY THAT.
IT SEEMS LIKE MOST OF OUR
ENFORCEMENT HAS BEEN ON THOSE
WHO ARE TRYING TO COMPLY.
AND I FIND THAT TO BE EXTREMELY
FRUSTRATING AND ALSO IMMORAL.
THAT WE SHOULD BE GOING AFTER
THESE NON COMPLIANT FOLKS WHO
ARE DOMINATING THE MARKET RIGHT
NOW WE WOULD AGREE AND THAT
THAT'S WHAT THESE RESOURCES ARE
DEDICATED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BUT BUT THESE RESOURCES THESE
ARE NOT PEACE OFFICER POSITIONS
AT THEIR AT THERE'S A NUMBER OF
THEM THAT ARE LIMITED PEACE
OFFICER WE DON'T HAVE FULL PEACE
OFFICER STATUS IN OUR DEPARTMENT.
WE WILL HAVE TO CANNABIS GROW IN
CALIFORNIA LEASE THE STATE.
CORRECT CORRECT AND I I MEAN
THAT THAT REALLY COMES BACK.
TO THE PRIORITIES WITH EDUCATION
AND OUTREACH ABSOLUTELY AND CAN
I ALSO ADD THAT -- I YOUR
REFERENCE OUT OF STATE -- I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE TWO THAT WE WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH A NUMBER OF
IT ENTITIES WE WORK WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS -- THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE C. H. P. -- SO WE ARE
NOT OPERATING IN A VACUUM WERE
VERY COLLABORATIVE WITH KEY
PARTNERS IN -- ADDRESSING
CANNABIS IS NOT SO HOW'S THAT
BEEN SO FAR A GOOD EXAMPLE IN
SACRAMENTO SACRAMENTO IS GROUND
ZERO FOR LISTA GROWS IN
RESIDENTIAL HOUSES.
IN THE NATION M. ARE YOU AWARE
THAT.
I AM NOW.
SO WHAT WHAT WHAT.
WHAT HAPPENS WITH THAT WHEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT SEARCH SEARCH
WARRANTS TYPICALLY MINISTRY
SEARCH WARRANTS THEY GO AND
BECAUSE THEY ARE COLLECTED TO
THE?
IF THE POWER GRID ILLEGALLY THEY
SHUT THAT DOWN LEAVE THE
MARIJUANA IN THERE YES I WOULD
HOPE THAT -- THE DEPARTMENT
WORKS WITH THAT TO TRY SECURE
LEGISLATION WE'RE LAW FOR
SHIPPING GOING TO DESTROY THE
MIDDLE EAST.
BECAUSE THE BOTTOM LINE IF LAW
ENFORCEMENT LEAVES THAT
MARIJUANA IN THOSE HOUSES IT
STILL MAKES IT OUT TO THE BLACK
MARKET.
SO I BELIEVE THE ENFORCEMENT
LEGAL MARKET IS IMPORTANT
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO STRUGGLE
WITH THE LEGAL MARKET.
BEFORE TAKE ACTION TO INCREASE
THE ENFORCEMENT LEGAL MARKET.
NEED HELP DISCUSSION ON THE
FORCE MEN AND DIRECTED AT THE
ILLEGAL MARKET.
LEGAL MARKET CONTINUES TO THRIVE
AND GROW WHICH UNDER BECAUSE
LEGAL PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
PLAYING BY THE RULES AND
THREATENED TO PUT THEM OUT OF
BUSINESS SO I HEARD YOU SAY
ABOUT THAT.
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO FOLKS ARE
STILL THE BLACK MARKET BUT THERE
AND GOT ONE FROM THE BLACK
MARKET ONE FOR THE LEGAL MARKET.
ON THAT ISSUE SO IT'S A REAL
IT'S IT'S A PROBLEM ANDYOU'RE
TACKLING A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
IT BUT BY FAR THE VAST MAJORITY
IS ILLEGAL MARKETING.
NELSON THESE FOLKS A PLAN IN
BOTH IN BOTH ROLES.
I THINK EVERYBODY HERE KNOWS
THAT ALICIA BLIND [inaudible]
YES.
YOU WANT TO COMMENT YES --
MICHAEL READY TO SEE THE TFA
INVESTIGATIONS I JUST WANTED.
TO KIND OF TOUCH ON THAT WE'RE
DOING A LOT OF THE PARTNERSHIP
FOR THE LOCAL JURISDICTION IS
MISTAKEN IS POINTED OUT.
AS WELL AS BUREAU CAMPUS CONTROL --
CANNABIS ENFORCEMENT UNIT.
WHICH IS TIED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS SO THAT
SEEMS THE COLLABORATION SEEMS TO
BE AN IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
EFFORTS TOWARDS TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE IN COMPLIANCE FOR DO YOU
HAVE ANY NUMBERS OR STATISTICS.
ABOUT WHAT YOU GUYS HAVE DONE
[inaudible]
THE WATSON.
YEAH I'D BE NICE OKAY -- SO
WE'VE DONE THIS IS LOCALIZED IN
THE LOS ANGELES AREA IS THIS IS
THIS IS THIS YOUR AGENCY DOING
IT TO YOUR AGENCY.
EXISTING LOCAL LOCALS WHO WERE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND WE'RE
JUST GOING ALONG WITH THEM
CORRECT THEM ON SEARCH WARRANTS
SAY IN THE IN THE LOS ANGELES
AREA BUT THE FOR THE FOR
SHIFTING OUT WITH THEM OR
TYPICALLY NON SWORN.
WERE LIMITED PEACE OFFICER SO WE
HAVE SEARCH WARRANT AUTHORITY
BUT ONE BUT WHEN YOU SAY LIMITED
PEACE OFFICERS THOSE ARE UNARMED
CORRECT THAT'S OR NOT.
NO NO WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT PLEASE
OFTEN.
THEY'RE NOT.
SALUTE TERM LIMIT PIECE AUTHORS
IS A VERY IS MISLEADING SO
THEY'RE NOT COPS NO NO THEY'RE
NOT OKAY.
THIS MAKES THANK YOU OKAY.
SO WE'VE GOT ABOUT TWO THIS IS
FOR A PILOT IN THE LOS ANGELES
AREA -- DONE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY VISITS -- WE'VE THAT
PARTICIPATED IN ABOUT SEVENTY
SEARCH WARRANTS WITH THE LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WE'VE HAD ABOUT -- FORTY SIX
CRIMINAL CITATIONS ISSUED AND WE
HAVE ABOUT -- FIVE CRIMINAL
CASES THAT ARE PENDING THAT
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE LOCAL
PROSECUTOR HOW MANY PLACES HAVE
BEEN CLOSED AS A RESULT OF THAT --
ABOUT SEVENTY NO EIGHTY ONE
COMPLAINTS HAVE BEEN CLOSED.
OUT OF THE TWO HUNDRED AND BUT
WHEN YOU SAY COMPLAINTS CLOSE
AND SALAS MY LAST QUESTION WE
GOT HERE.
WE SAY COMPLAINTS CLOSE OR IS
THE OPERATION CLOSE THAT'S RIGHT
THE OPERATION IS CLOSE.
SO THE PLACES BEEN SHUT DOWN
CLOSED [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE WHOLE THIS ITEM OPEN.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY FOR SOME COUPLE
NUMBERS TO THE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT.
THE DIRECTION WE'RE HEADED IN.
SOMEWHAT OUR NEXT ITEM I'M
NUMBER -- TWELVE TAX IF YOU
PROGRAM'S GIRLS OFFICE OF TAX
APPEALS WORKLOAD.
GREAT -- IN JANUARY THE OFFICE
OF IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
OFFICES TAX PILLS IMPLEMENTED
THE NEW ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING
PROCESS OF TAX APPEALS.
WHICH INCREASE THE CDC FAA'S
WORKLOAD FROM APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY FORTY EIGHTY HOURS TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY HOURS FOR EACH TAX
DEAL.
INVOLVING LEGAL ISSUES AND FROM
THREE HOURS TO TWENTY HOURS FOR
EACH TAX BILL INVOLVING AUDIT
ISSUES.
THE CD TFA REQUEST FOLLOWING
RESOURCES ONE MILLION FOR SIX
PERMANENT POSITIONS IN FISCAL
YEAR.
NINETEEN TWENTY AN EIGHT HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND FOR
FISCAL YEAR ON GOING.
HELLO.
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS FINANCE.
THE QUESTION COMMITTEE.
WHICH IS AREA THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I MAKE.
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK A
FEW QUESTIONS AND I'M I'M HAPPY
TO ROLL IT ALL INTO ONE IF YOU
CAN REMEMBER THE QUESTIONS ALSO --
WANTED TO JUST GET A SENSE OF
HOW YOUR WORK HAS BEEN -- WITH
THE THE APPEALS PROCESS HAS BEEN
GOING FORWARD WITH UNDER OTA
GIVEN THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION THAT IT WAS AND
SO IF YOU CAN TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT JUST THE DIFFERENCES THE
RIVER.
AND THEN ALSO THE ROLLOUT
PROCESS OF HOW IT'S BEEN IT'S
RELATIVELY NEW YEAR AND A HALF
SO -- IF YOU CAN TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT.
WHAT CHALLENGES THERE BEEN AND --
AND AND AND OR HOW MAY BE
POTENTIALLY IT'S ALSO BECOME
EASIER -- TO MOVE FORWARD -- AND
ALSO IF YOU CAN TOUCH UPON A
LITTLE BIT ON THE INTERACTION
BETWEEN -- OF THE D. O. T. A.
AND AND TAXPAYERS IN THIS
PROCESS -- I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE
WITH THE OTHER QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU AND I FAST I'M
OUR CHIEF COUNSEL INTERIM CHIEF
COUNSEL BOB TUCKER HE IS THE
RESIDENT EXPERT ON THIS TOPIC SO
HE'S GOING TO HELP AT RESPOND TO
QUESTIONS.
YES -- BOB TUCKER CITY CAFE --
IT'S PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCES IT COMES DOWN TO THE
TRANSPARENCY.
RIGHT NOW WITH O'DONNELL
EVERYTHING TAKES PLACE IN A
FORUM WHERE -- WE HAVE
CONFERENCES WE HAVE PRE HEARING
CONFERENCES THERE IS BRIEFING
THAT GOES BACK AND FORTH
ALTHOUGH.
THIS TOOK PLACE ON A LIMITED
BASIS BEFORE MUCH OF WHAT
OCCURRED OCCURRED ACTUALLY IN
THE MEMBERS OFFICES OUTSIDE OF
ANY OUTSIDE OF OUR REVIEW AND IT
WAS DONE AND AN EX PARTE FASHION.
MEANING THAT WE WEREN'T SIMPLY A
PART OF IT WHATSOEVER.
SO -- IF THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
STEPS THERE ARE -- ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE MEET IN
ORDER SO -- THAT CAN -- PREPARE
AND PROVIDE A WRITTEN RESPONSE
AND PROVIDE A BRIEF.
THAT IS AVAILABLE ON THE THERE --
WEB PAGES.
BUT WE SEE THAT AS AN ADVANTAGE
IT GIVES -- SUNLIGHT TO WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
THE ROLL OUT IT'S IT'S TAKEN
SUMMIT ADAPT THE IN -- THEY'RE
IMPLEMENTING A NEW PROCESS AND
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT SIMPLY
DIDN'T EXIST BEFORE.
SO WE HAVE.
SPENT SIGNIFICANT TIME WORKING
WITH A WITH A DEVELOPING
PROCESSES.
SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE -- THE
INFORMATION THAT'S NECESSARY.
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE IT AS I SAID
A TRANSPARENT PROCESS WITH THE
TAXPAYERS THEY IMPLEMENTED THE
REGULATIONS WHICH CAME ON BOARD
AT THE END OF LAST YEAR.
AND IT'S A IT.
IN SOME REGARDS IT'S U. S.
WHAT'S EASIER IT'S EASIER
BECAUSE IT IS TRANSPARENT AND
IT'S EASIER BECAUSE IT IS OUT IN
THE SUNLIGHT -- IT'S MORE WORK
FOR US BUT IT'S WORK THAT'S
WE'RE HAPPY TO DO AND I THINK
IT'S WORK THAT'S NECESSARY SO
THAT WE HAVE THIS TRANSPARENT
PROCESS.
AS TO THE INTERACTION BETWEEN
ODIN THAT TAX PAYERS.
WE'RE NOT PRIVY TO MUCH OF THAT
BUT I KNOW THEY'VE HAD
SIGNIFICANT -- MEETINGS --
INTERESTED PARTIES MEETINGS FOR
THE COURTS OF THE REGULATIONS.
THEY HAVE -- PLACE THEIR
INFORMATION OUT ON THE WEB PAGE
SO IT'S AVAILABLE FOR TAXPAYERS
TO CONTACT THEM.
AND IT IT APPEARS THAT THEY'RE
DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
MAKE THEMSELVES AVAILABLE.
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THE CHANGE IN
NUMBERS.
OF TAXPAYER SERVED AND THE
PROCESS -- WE HAVE IT IT'S WE
HAVE NOT HAD AS MANY HEARINGS IN
THE FIRST YEAR.
THERE WAS A RAMP UP PERIOD AND
IF BEGINNING AROUND DECEMBER OF
LAST YEAR IT'S STARTING TO
INCREASE.
SO THAT THEY WERE FOCUSING ON IF --
INCOME TAX IF THE FOR PERHAPS
YES BUT AS FAR AS FOR OUR CASES
WITH CD TFA WE'RE STARTING TO
SEE A ROLL OUT AND AS THEY USE --
ARE IMPLEMENTING THEIR PROCESSES
WE'RE SEEING MORE AND MORE
HEARINGS.
SO WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT --
TRANSPARENCY AND SOME LIKE --
WHAT'S BEEN A DIFFERENCE IN THE
PUBLISHED OPINIONS. ONE BECAUSE
THERE ARE THEIR WORK PUBLISHED
OPINIONS BEFORE SO THAT'S A HUGE
DIFFERENCE -- IT'S A CHANCE FOR
PEOPLE TO SEE AND UNDERSTAND THE
REASONING THE LOGIC THAT GOES
INTO THE DECISION THAT WAS MADE.
AS OPPOSED TO BEFORE UNDER THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION THERE WAS
SIMPLY A DECISION WITH NO
EXPLANATION BECAUSE OF MY EX
PARTE COMMUNICATION WHAT.
THIS PERHAPS BECAUSE THAT BUT
ALSO BECAUSE THE BOARD DID NOT
TYPICALLY PUBLISHER WRITTEN
DECISION SO IT WAS SIMPLY DONE
WITH AN IRON ARE NAY THERE AT
THE BOARD AND SO YOU WOULDN'T.
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE NECESSARILY
KNOW WHY OR WHAT THEIR LOGIC WAS
AND NOW HERE EVERYTHING CAN BE
EXAMINED -- IF IF WE WERE.
TO HAVE AN ISSUE WITH THE
DECISION OR IF THE TAXPAYER WERE
TO HAVE AN ISSUE WITH A DECISION.
THEY SEE THE LOGIC LAID OUT IN
FRONT OF THEM AND THEY CAN FILE
A PETITION FOR REHEARING.
SO IT I AS I SAID I THINK IT
MAKES A PROCESS THAT IS.
OFF ONCE AGAIN -- MORE OPEN TO
THE PUBLIC MORE TRANSPARENT.
WHICH I BELIEVE WAS THE STATED
GOAL ALL PARK FIGURE HOW MANY
OPINIONS YOU THINK YOU'VE -- AND
THE LAST THE HERE YEAR
INFORMANTS WE ALL.
WE HAVE BRIEFED THE NUMBER OF
CASES -- PROBABLY A COUPLE
HUNDRED WE'VE HAD -- THE CASES
BEGAN PRIMARILY IN DECEMBER AND
WE'VE HAD PROBABLY THIRTY TO
FORTY CASES I THINK BY NOW.
THAT.
AND A MISTER ZICK NAZARIAN IF I
COULD ADD -- AS I MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY WHEN YOU ASK A
QUESTION ABOUT REDIRECTING
RESOURCES -- THIS IS ANOTHER
AREA WHERE THE WORKLOAD IS THERE
NOW AND SO WE'VE REDIRECTED
POSITIONS FROM WITHIN THREE AM.
NON PROVISION ONE POSITIONS FROM
OTHER US SUPPORT AREAS AND WE'D
LIKE TO MOVE TO FROM THE
INVESTIGATIONS DIVISION -- THAT
ARE DESIGNATED AS PROVISION ONE
SO AGAIN WE'RE WE'RE NOT ASKING
FOR POSITIONS WERE JUST ASKING
FOR THE AUTHORITY TO USE OUR
POSITIONS AND THEN A FUNDING
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THEM I AM IN
COMPLETE SUPPORT OF WHAT THE A
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR JUST
MENTIONED.
AWHILE AGO I I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR YOU TO NOT BE
SHACKLED WITH THE RESTRICTIONS
THAT WERE PLACED BECAUSE OF
POTENTIALLY -- SOME DISCRETION
THAT VERSION WAS NOT USED IN
PREVIOUS.
A CIRCUMSTANCES SO I I'D BE VERY
MUCH SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT HE SAID --
HOW SO HOW MANY APPEALS THE
EXPECTED ON AN ONGOING BASIS? TO
COME UP.
AGAIN BALLPARK RIGHT HE HAD OVER
TO HOLD YOU TO HIT HIM THING AS
YOU'RE TRYING TO GUESSTIMATE IT
WILL HISTORICALLY -- WE HAVE
APPEAL THAT WE REGARD AS LEGAL
APPEALS IN APPEALS THAT WE
REGARD AS AUDIT APPEALS --
TYPICALLY WE'VE HAD ABOUT A
HUNDRED LEGAL APPEALS IN A YEAR
AND WEEK WE'RE ESTIMATING
BETWEEN HUNDRED HUNDRED FIFTIETH
THINK AND THAT WOULD BE THE
WORKLOAD FOR THE STAFF.
AND IN THE LAST NINE MONTHS -- I
THINK WE'RE PRETTY CLOSE.
IF IF IF THE IF MY NOTES SERVE
ME CORRECTLY I THINK A UP
PREVIOUSLY IN THE LAST TEN YEARS
THERE'S ONLY BEEN TWO PUBLISHED.
OPINIONS YEAH UP PRIOR TO CD TFA
SO -- I AM.
VERY PLEASED TO HEAR.
OF WHERE THE WHERE THE WITH THE
CHANGE FROM A YEAR AND A HALF
AGO IT'S TAKEN.
YOUR ADMINISTRATION AND HOW IT'S
IMPROVING UPON THE PROCESS IF WE
KEEP ON CHANGING THE GOAL POST
THERE BECAUSE THERE'S GOING TO
BE NO CONFIDENCE.
IN THE PROCESS SO THE SANCTITY
OF ALL OF THIS IS DEPENDENT ON
HOW WELL THE PROCESS WORKS. TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK AND
THANKS FOR ANSWERING SOME OF
THESE QUESTIONS THANK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS PROPOSED
BUDGET IS OUR MOTION.
ROLL CALL PLEASE [inaudible]
COOPER HI. TO LACKEY.
NAZARIAN.
WICKS. ONE IS NEVER THIRTEEN
SETTLEMENT TAXPAYERS SERVICES
BUREAU -- OKAY -- THE CITY TFA
ADMINISTERS MORE THAN THIRTY TAX
AND FEE PROGRAMS THAT GENERATE
REVENUE ESSENTIAL TO THE STATE
CALIFORNIA.
THE SETTLEMENTS AND TAXPAYERS
SERVICES BUREAU ADMINISTERS THE
CD TFA SETTLEMENT PROGRAM.
BYEFFICIENTLY NEGOTIATING AND
RESOLVING DISPUTED TAX
LIABILITIES IN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE APPEALS PROCESS.
SOME APRIL REQUEST PERMANENT
ESTABLISHMENT OF SIX POSITIONS
SYSTEM.
IT'S THE SAME NUMBER I'M SORRY
YEAH THIS IS -- AT SIX LIMITED
TERM WE HAVE SIX LIMITED TERM
POSITION SET TO EXPIRE -- THAT'S
RIGHT IN JUNE OF THIS YEAR --
AND ONE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
TWENTY ON GOING TO ADDRESS A
HUNDRED AND 81% INCREASE.
IN TAXPAYER DEMAND FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE SETTLEMENTS WITH
THE SETTLEMENT PROGRAM FROM A
TWENTY TEN TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE CITY TFA EXPECTS THESE SIX
POSITIONS TOOK SALARY COLLECTION
OF NEARLY FORTY THREE POINT
EIGHT MILLION.
AND ADDITIONAL REVENUE ANNUALLY
SO WE DO HAVE -- THE STAFF TO
CURRENTLY -- BUT THEY'RE LIMITED
TERM POSITIONS THAT ARE SET TO
EXPIRE IN JUNE AND WE WOULD LIKE
TO EXTEND THOSE.
CREATE THEM PERMANENTLY.
LL.
I WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSED RESOURCES THE SOME OF
THE WORKLOAD PROJECTIONS IN THE
PROPOSAL SEEM TO SUGGEST THAT
THE PROPOSED RESOURCES WOULD NOT
BE ADEQUATE AND THAT -- BACKLOG
COULD CONTINUE IN THE PROGRAM WE
VIEW THOSE WORKLOAD PROJECTIONS
AS LIKELY TO HIGH AND AND THINK
THAT THE WORK LOAD LIKELY
MATCHES -- PRETTY WELL WITH THE
PROPOSED RESOURCES.
FINANCE.
MAKING THESE PERMANENT MATCHES
THE WORKLOAD.
THE QUESTION ON THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS ERIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- IN.
ALONG THE LINES OF PROCESS I
WANTED TO ASK IF THE A YOU CAN
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
SETTLEMENT PROCESS.
IN THIS IN THIS ARENA -- I GUESS
THE BEST EXPLANATION TO BE THAT
THE SETTLEMENT -- BUREAU IS
AVAILABLE FOR TAXPAYERS WHEN
THEY'RE IN THEIR ADMINISTRATIVE
APPEALS PROCESS.
AND AT ANY TIME IF THEY DECIDE
THAT THEY WISH -- TO MORE LET'S
PUT THAT ADMINISTRATIVE APPEALS --
PROCESS ON HOLD THERE WERE ABLE
TO COME TO OUR SETTLEMENT BUREAU.
AND AT THAT TIME.
THE SETTLEMENT BUREAU IS ABLE TO
WORK WITH THEM -- TO LOOK AT THE
RISK OF LITIGATION AND TO WORK
ON A SETTLEMENT PROPOSAL.
AND WHICH THEY DEVELOP A NUMBER
THAT IN ESSENCE ALLOWS.
THEM TO AS WITH STATE BEFORE
ACCELERATE THE REVENUE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT.
IT SHORT CUTS THAT
ADMINISTRATIVE APPEALS PROCESS
PROVIDE CERTAINTY AND THEN --
PUTS AN END OF THAT PROCESS TO
IT IT'S A MEANS WHICH IT CAN.
REDUCE THE COSTS.
RATHER THAN GOING THROUGH AN
EXTENSIVE ADMINISTAFF'S BEER.
FOR THE TAXPAYER IN FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR BOTH
BECAUSE I THINK.
I'VE SPENT TWENTY YEARS WORKING
ON ADMINISTRATIVE APPEALS AND I
THINK ONE THING THAT PEOPLE
FORGET OR THEY SOMETIMES DON'T
FOCUS ON THEIR COSTS FOR
TAXPAYERS AN ADMINISTRATIVE
APPEAL.
IT'S NOT JUST THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO IF PEOPLE UTILIZE
THE SETTLEMENT BUREAU THEY CAN
ALLOW THEM.
TO AT THEIR OWN WILL THEY CAN
REDUCE THEIR COSTS AS WELL.
SO HOW'S THAT HOW HOW -- HOW
REGULAR HAS THE ENGAGEMENT AND I
WANT TO PUT WORDS IN SO?
HAS THERE BEEN A REGULAR
ENGAGEMENT WITH TAXPAYERS HAS
THERE BEEN AN INCREASE IN
REGULAR ENGAGEMENT -- BY ARE YOU
BY ENGAGEMENT YOU MEAN LIKE
PERSONAL INTERACTION OR DO YOU
MEAN SIMPLY SETTLEMENT -- THE
NEEDLE IN SETTLEMENT THROUGH THE
PROCESS THAT YOU HAVE FAILED --
HOUSE THEY CHANGED.
IT'S WELL IT THE ADVANTAGE THAT
WE HAVE IS WITH AN OFFICE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AT AT LAW IT
ALLOWS FOR PERSONAL INTERACTION
AND IT ALLOWS -- FOR INDIVIDUALS
BECAUSE IT'S NOT NECESSARILY A
PROFESSIONAL REPRESENTATIVE
SOMETIMES IT'S AN INDIVIDUAL OF
HIS OR HER OWN ACCORD COMING IN.
AND WANTED TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
IT AND SO IT'S NOT.
I THINK ONE OF THE UNIQUE THINGS
WE HAVE IT'S IT'S NOT A OVERLY
FORMAL PROCESS IT ALLOWS AN
INDIVIDUAL BUSINESS PERSON AND
MANY OF THESE BUSINESS PEOPLE
ARE SMALL. FOR LIKE A BETTER
DESCRIPTION MOM AND POP
BUSINESSES OFTEN HAVE GONE OUT
OF BUSINESS AND INFO HERE
ANYWHERE TO COLLECT SO IT GIVES
THEM AND AN OPPORTUNITY -- TO
HAVE PERSONAL INTERACTION AND TO
DO IT IN A MUCH QUICKER FASHION
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE MEETING IN
PERSON A ITS EASIER THAN --
DOING SO BY MAIL OR EVEN BY
PHONE BECAUSE YOU'RE ABLE TO EXT
IF YOU HAVE THE RECORDS THERE.
YOU CAN ADDRESS IT INSTANTLY AS
OPPOSED -- TO TAKING DAYS OR
WEEKS SO IT'S LESSEN THE ANXIETY
AND THE BURDEN ON THE TAXPAYER.
I WILDLY HOLDS US.
I WOULD HOPE SO MORE DIRECTLY
ACCESSIBLE.
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU CAN ALLOW ME
FOR A COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS
ABSOLUTELY -- SO.
IF IF WITHOUT THESE NEW
POSITIONS WHAT SORT OF
REPERCUSSIONS.
WOULD THERE BE.
IT IT IT WILL IT WILL I AM THE
SEMINAL INCREASE OUR WORKLOAD IN
THAT WE WOULD LOSE THE SIX
POSITIONS AND IT COULD
ULTIMATELY LEAD TO A BACKLOG
WHICH WOULD MEAN -- SETTLEMENTS
NOT BEING HANDLED THIS TIMELY --
TAXPAYERS NOT GETTING THEIR
RESOLUTION IS TIMELY.
SO IN DOING SO IT AFFORDS
INCREASED REVENUE TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
INCREASED CERTAINTY TO TAXPAYERS
AND I'M ASSUMING IT MAKES.
ONCE THEY COMPLETE THEIR
ADMINISTRATIVE MATTER I'M SURE
THAT MAKES IT EASIER FOR THEM AS
WELL.
IT JUST REDUCES THEIR ANXIETY
BUT I THINK I'D BE BELIEVE BRING
THE POINT IF I A ASKED YOU TO
MAKE A COMPARISON AND COMPARE
CONTRAST.
BETWEEN THE PROCESS YOU HAVE NOW
FOR SETTLEMENT VERSUS THE OF THE
THE PROCESS.
DURING THE B. O. E..
ADMINISTRATION OF THIS AREA BUT
IF THERE'S SOMETHING THAT YOU
HAVEN'T SAID THAT YOU'D LIKE.
TO AYE AYE TRIBUTE -- AT I I
JUST THINK THAT NOW WE HAVE --
STAFF IS.
BETTER TO SAY THAT WE'RE VERY
HAPPY.
IT'S A IT'S GIVES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR STAFF -- TO TO PERFORM THEIR
ABILITY WITHOUT.
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WE FACE
THE WITH.
IN THE PAST AND AT CENTCOM.
I'M GLAD THAT YOU BROUGHT THAT
UP BECAUSE I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU AND THINK
ABOUT.
CONTINUING THESE COMPLICATIONS
AS WELL SALUTE SO APPRECIATE YOU
MENTIONING THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OPEN UP PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY RECOMMENDATIONS TO PROVE
HIS PROPOSED -- IS OUR MOTION.
OKAY ROLL CALL PLEASE COOPER HI
TO LACKEY MISSOURIAN.
WICKS.
KO SIX THIS ISSUE NUMBER
FOURTEEN PREPAID SERVICES MTS
SURCHARGE SURCHARGE MOBILE.
ALL RIGHT -- ON NOVEMBER
FIFTEENTH TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE U. S. DISTRICT COURT FOUND
THAT THE STATE PORTION OF THE
PREPAID MOBILE TELEPHONE THE
SERVICES -- MTS PROGRAM WAS
INVALID AS A RESULT THE CV TFA
STOPPED COLLECTING THE STATE
PORTION OF THE PROGRAM BUT
CONTINUES TO COLLECT THE LOCAL
PORTION.
UNTIL IT SUNSET ON DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS FOR
STATE ADMINISTRATIVE MANUAL
REQUIREMENTS CD TFA WILL
CONTINUE TO MANAGE OPERATING
REQUIREMENTS -- SUCH AS REFUNDS
FEES ETCETERA ON THE RELATED
STATE AND LOCAL FUNDS UNTIL
THREE YEARS POST EXPIRATION. TO
ABIDE OUT OF THE RELATED FUNDS
THE CD TFA RECOMMENDS A
REDUCTION IN RESOURCES. TO
EFFICIENTLY CONCLUDE THE PREPAID
MTS SURCHARGE COLLECTION ACT
PROGRAM AS FOLLOWS.
A REDUCTION OF ONE MILLION AND
EIGHT POINT FOR POSITIONS IN
FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY
REDUCTION OF ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION AND THIRTEEN POINT SIX
POSITIONS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE A REDUCTION OF
ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION AND
THIRTEEN POINT SIX POSITIONS IN.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO REDUCTION
OF ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION AND
FOURTEEN POINT ONE POSITIONS IN.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
FINALLY A REDUCTION OF ONE POINT
EIGHT AND FOURTEEN POINT SIX
POSITIONS IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AN ON GOING [inaudible]
LL.
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS FINANCE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OVER THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEC WE WANT SPEAKER.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAID TANK
YOU'RE GONNA BE HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CITIES.
OF ONE OF THE NOTES IN THE
ANALYSIS IT IT IT POINTS OUT OF
THAT THERE IS -- THIS OTHER
PROGRAM TO LOCAL PREPAID M. T.
S. -- COLLECTION ACT OF THAT
ACTUALLY IS A PROGRAM THAT WE AT
THE LEGAL LIKE TO SEE CONTINUED --
IT DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
DIRECTLY WITH THIS WITH THIS
DECISION THAT WAS REFERENCED --
WHAT THE ISSUE INVOLVES IS ON
WHEN YOU -- WHEN YOU HAVE A CELL
PHONE LIKE THE US IN YOU AND THE
LOCAL CITY OR COUNTY HAS UTILITY
USERS TAX YOU OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
A WAY FOR THE CITY OR COUNTY TO
COLLECT THE U. U. T.?
HOWEVER THE CHALLENGE WAS AS
INDIVIDUALS MOVED OVER TO
PREPAID WHEN THEY WERE BUYING
PREPAID CARDS.
I WAS HARDER TO COLLECT THERE
WAS LEGISLATION THAT WAS WORKED
WITH ALL THAT WORKED OUT WITH
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT THREE
YEARS AGO IT RESULTED IN THIS
PROGRAM.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTEEN US CITIES AND
COUNTIES AROUND THE THE STATE
THAT ARE -- USING THE PROGRAM I
THINK IT'S COLLECTED ABOUT
TWENTY THREE MILLION REVENUE
IT'S WORKING -- WELL AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE SEE IF WE CAN HAVE
THIS PROGRAM CONTINUED.
SO.
THAT'S MY COM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RECOGNITION IS TO PROVE HIS
PROPOSED.
OF THE MOTION.
OKAY WILL HELP PLEASE COOPER HI
[inaudible]
TO LACKEY NAZARIAN.
WHICH TAKES US TO ITEM FIFTEEN
COMMUNITY BASED TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM A LOT OF TIME
LINE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHRIS STILL THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
EXISTING LOST OUT WHICH IS
COMMUNITY BASED TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM OF PURSUANT TO
THAT PROGRAM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS AWARDED -- GRANTS TO
FOURTEEN LOCAL AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE ON HOUSING -- TO PERSONS
IN NEED INCLUDING EX OFFENDERS
AND ONE OF THE PROVISIONS OF
THAT -- THE ENACTING LEGISLATION
CALLS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO DO A PERFORMER.
A REVIEW OF THE PROGRAM BY MAY
FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND DUE TO
VARIOUS INTERNAL CIRCUMSTANCES --
FINANCES UNABLE TO MEET THAT
DEADLINE SO WE'RE SEEKING TO
EXTEND THAT -- MAY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN DEADLINE BUT
WHEN YOU'RE TO MAY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY AND WE'RE
ALSO SEEKING -- TO INSTEAD OF
DOING A REVIEW WE'RE SEEKING TO
HAVE AUTHORIZATION TO DO AN
AUDIT BECAUSE THAT WOULD ALLOW
FOR GREATER PROBITY AND ALLOW US
TO DELVE DEEPER INTO HOW THE
MONEY WAS USED BY THE PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS -- I KNOW THAT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE -- ASKS THEM IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF NOTES THAT
THERE'S A COMMENT -- ASKED
PARTNER FINANCE WITH THE TIME
LINE WOULD LOOK LIKE FOR THE
AUDIT -- WE THINK IT BE ABOUT
SIX MONTHS TO DO THAT -- THAT
WOULD INCLUDE -- TIME TO DEVELOP
THE AUDIT GUIDELINES AND
SPECIFICATIONS -- TO DO
NOTIFICATIONS TO THE FOURTEEN
PARTICIPANTS.
AND ALSO TO GO OUT AND DO FIELD
WORK AND TO DEVELOP FINDINGS AND
THE RIGHT THE FINAL REPORT
[inaudible]
HELLO.
SO WE'RE OBVIOUSLY WERE PASSED
MAY FIRST -- YOU TO ASK YOU FOR
SIX MORE MONTHS COMPLETED -- ONE
YEARS WHEN YOU I'M SORRY IT IS
THE WORK BEEN DONE UP UNTIL NOW
OUR UNFORTUNATELY NOT -- THAT
HAS NOT.
OTHER WORKLOAD PRIORITIES WERE
COMPETING IN THERE IS -- FINANCE
UNFORTUNATELY WE JUST -- DIDN'T
COMMUNICATE AS WELL INTERNALLY
AS WE SHOULD HAVE MISTAKES WERE
MADE -- SO -- THEREFORE WE WE
PUT REACHED REQUEST AS
ADDITIONAL YEAR SO HOW LONG AGO
WAS THIS AUDIT FIRST ASKED --
FOR THE LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZING
LEGISLATION -- WAS ENACTED.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN I
BELIEVE.
SO WELL THREE YEARS.
THE QUESTION THE COMMITTEE -- UP
UP TO PUT PUBLIC COMMENT.
INNOVATION SPEAK.
I WAS GONNA TELL YOU.
AND LET'S NOT AND LET ME KILL
MESSENGER BUT THREE YEARS IS
RIDICULOUS.
I MEAN IT'S IT'S WITH A THREE
YEAR SPAN OTHER ONE SIX MORE
MONTHS.
SO THAT'S YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S
ACCEPTABLE BUT AS GOVERNMENT --
WELL I I IS INDIVIDUAL WHO
DRAFTED THE TRAILER BILL IN
KINDA SHEPHERDED THROUGH THE
PROCESS I'M HAPPY TO TAKE THE
FALL FOR THIS ONE BECAUSE I
THINK WE COULD HAVE DONE A
BETTER JOB AND THAT WAS.
ON ME OKAY YOU CAN TAKE IT --
RECOGNITION TO DOT THE PLACE OF
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
THEIR MOTION.
CAROL CALL PLEASE COOPER HI.
TO LACKEY WINDSOR IN
[inaudible]
WICKS. SIX IS TO SIXTEEN
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION PLAN.
THE TO MICHAEL [inaudible]
IT'S YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH. THREE **** YEARS.
YEAH.
HELLO -- THIS [inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON AFTERNOON THIS
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO DISCUSS THESE TO
FUNDING REQUEST.
MY NAME IS RICK MORE AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER WITH A MORE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS LANCE
PERSON GEOLOGIST.
THESE FUNDING REQUEST IF
APPROVED WILL ALLOW OUR PROGRAMS
TAKE NEXT STEP FORWARD IN
PROVIDING IMPROVE SERVICES TO
THOSE SEEKING PROFESSIONAL
LICENSURE IN CALIFORNIA.
MY BOARD IS ONE OF THE PROGRAMS
FOR LIST ALONG IN THIS PROCESS.
AND AS WE PROCEEDED THROUGH THIS
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION.
COLLECTIVELY WE'VE INVESTED
HUNDREDS OF NOT THOUSANDS OF
STAFF HOURS AND PREPARING
OURSELVES FOR SUCCESS IN MEETING
THESE COMMODITIZATION GOALS.
THIS INCLUDES DIAGRAM BUSINESS
PROCESSES IDENTIFYING SYSTEM
REQUIREMENTS IN REVIEWING
POTENTIAL SOFTWARE PLATFORMS.
WE'VE ALSO INVESTORS SHOULD A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF TIME
WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENTS OF
TECHNOLOGY AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. TO UNDERSTAND AND
IMPROVE AND OBTAIN APPROVAL TO
THE STATE'S PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE PROCESS.
WE BELIEVE THIS MATTER OF EFFORT
IS CRITICAL TOWARDS ESTABLISHING
A PROPER FOUNDATION. FOR THE
BUSINESS AND TECHNOLOGY
INITIATIVES THAT WILL IMPROVE
THE WAY WE DELIVER SERVICES TO
THE PUBLIC.
STAFF MEMBERS ARE COLLECTED
PROGRAMS OF RECOGNIZE THE NEED
FOR BETTER SOLUTIONS.
ARE EAGER AND FULLY COMMITTED TO
MAKE THIS EFFORT A SUCCESS.
WE HAVE EVERY EXPECTATION THAT
BY CONTINUING DEPARTMENT WITH A
PARTNER WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND TECHNOLOGY
WE WILL MEET OUR GOALS IN THAT
RESPECT.
ARE CLOSE BY SAYING THAT WE HOPE
YOU WILL SUPPORT BOTH FUNDING
REQUEST SO THAT ALL SIX PROGRAMS
CAN CONTINUE MAKING PROGRESS.
INDUSTRY IN THEIR RESPECTIVE
MODERNIZATION EFFORTS.
NEXT FISCAL YEAR.
BOREDOM BUREAU PROGRAM
LEADERSHIP AND REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE DEPARTMENTS ARE ALL
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME [inaudible]
L. L..
INCREASING AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AS THE
COMMITTEE MAY RECALL AND
PREVIOUSLY WE HAD SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO
HAVING THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
VARIOUS BOARDS IN BUREAUS I
REPORT ON THEIR APPROACH. TO
THIS PROJECT ON SUBSEQUENTLY
STAFF AS IS INDICATED IN YOUR
AGENDA HAVE MET WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND GOTTEN SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
I'M TO THE EXTENT THE COMMITTEE
IS COMFORTABLE WITH THE
INFORMATION THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED --
WE DON'T SEE A REASON WHY THAT
THE PROJECT SHOULD MOVE FORWARD
WE ARE HOWEVER PROPOSING AND
SOUND BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE WHICH
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE BUDGET
BILLING WHICH WERE PROPOSING --
FOR OTHER PROJECTS I T. PROJECTS
ACROSS THE STATE THAT ARE SORT
OF IN A SIMILAR SITUATION AND
THAT WOULD BASICALLY CONDITION
THE FUNDING ON THE PELL PROCESS.
I REACHING ITS CONCLUSION SO
CURRENTLY THESE.
PROJECTS ARE MIDWAY THROUGH THE
POWER PROCESS THAT COMPLETED
STAGE -- TO AND SO THERE'S A
COST ESTIMATE BUT IT HAS BEEN
FULLY FLESHED OUT REFINED ON A
SEPTIC SYSTEM POTENTIAL CHANGES
AND SO WE'RE RECOMMENDING SOME.
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD -- THAT
WOULD JUST TAKE THAT UP A LITTLE
BIT.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
HE TRIED APARTMENT A FINANCE WE
JUST WANT TO STRESS THAT THE
FUNDING REQUEST IS FOR WHEN
YOU'RE ONLY TO LEATHER PARCHMENT --
TO TO BEGIN IMPLEMENTATION
ACTIVITIES IN NINETEEN TWENTY
THE DEPARTMENT WILL HAVE TO
REQUEST SUBSEQUENT FUNDING.
AFTER COMPLETING STAGE FOUR OF
THE PROJECT APPROVAL LIFE CYCLE.
THROUGH THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS -- DUE TO THE EXTENSIVE
WORK THAT -- IT'S BEEN COMPLETED
BY DCA AND THE BOARDS DURING THE
MARKET RESEARCH AND PLANNING
PHASES.
WE FEEL THAT THE ESTIMATES IN
THE STAGE TO DOCUMENTATION ARE
REASONABLE AND THAT WHEN YOU'RE
FUNDING IS A PERMIT TO AVOID
POTENTIAL DELAYS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
INCOME IS THE COMMITTEE.
THE SURGEON SO I KNOW I HAVE.
THESE FOR SEVEN A REGULAR CRITIC
OF THIS PROJECT -- I APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE SINCE
THE LAST HEARING I KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN.
A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS THERE'S AN
UPDATED SCHEDULE -- THEIR NEW
DATES AND I THINK THAT'S ALL
GOOD I ALSO KNOW THAT DCA IS HAD
A NUMBER OF MEETINGS WITH STAFF
ON OUR SIDE.
ABOUT HOW TO IMPLEMENT THIS AND
AND SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
TODAY -- BUT I WANNA SAY -- THAT
OBVIOUSLY WILL BE MONITORING
THIS CLOSELY AND WHEN THIS COMES
BACK TO US NEXT YEAR.
IF THESE DATES HAVE SLIPPED I
WANT TO GET AN UPDATE OF THAT IN
THE NEXT.
HEARING AND I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
A REPRESENTATIVE OF THAT BORDER
BUREAU HERE TO EXPLAIN TO US A
YEAR FROM NOW WHY THINGS HAVE
SLIPPED.
A MENTION I SERVE ON THE
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE
THAT OVERSEES A LOT OF THESE
PORTS AND BUREAUS AND I HAVE TO
ADMIT THAT THE FAILURES WITH THE
COURSE OF THESE PROJECTS HAVE
SOARED COLORED SOME OF MY
PERSPECTIVE ON THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF BOARDS AND HERE'S ANOTHER
CATEGORY SO I JUST.
WANT TO SAY THAT LOOK FOR TO FOR
PROGRESS ON THIS -- BUT I DO
PLAN TO AND I'M HAPPY TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD I JUST WANNA SAY
ONE LAST THING I KNOW ON A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT ISSUE THAT
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE IS
PUTTING IN LANGUAGE. TO
PRIORITIZE FUNDING AROUND -- AB --
TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT
REGULATIONS AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT I KNOW.
THAT WAS A BIG DISCUSSION THAT
WE HAD WITH THE CA WHAT THE
GOVERNOR LAST YEAR AND AND I
DIDN'T THINK THAT WE COULD.
ACTUALLY CARRY OUT THAT LAW
WITHOUT REAL FUNDING -- AND SO I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT WILL BE IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET -- OR THESE
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL WITH THAT
HAVING TO MOVE THE MOTION
[inaudible]
MOST OF SEC -- DELICIOUS BECOMES
ITEM [inaudible]
THIS IS.
ROLL CALL PLEASE [inaudible]
COOPER HI. TWO FIVE LACKEY.
IS THERE IN [inaudible]
WICKS.
Q. SERVICE TORRES ITEM.
ITEM
[inaudible]
SEVENTEEN GOOD AFTERNOON.
OF THE ISSUE FOR YOU -- THE THE
ISSUE BEFORE YOU PROPOSES
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO MAKE A
TECHNICAL CORRECTION TO RESTORE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
SECTION.
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE WHICH
ELIMINATED THE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY FOR THE BUREAU TO
COLLECT -- INITIATE INITIAL
REGISTRATION AND RENEWAL FEES
FOR SERVICE CONTRACTORS.
THIS WAS NOT INTENTIONAL AS
EVERY OTHER SECTION OF THE LAW
DEALING WITH THE SERVICE
CONTRACTORS WAS.
GRANTED DURING THE SUNSET
EXTENSION LAST YEAR.
AND I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
FORGOTTEN THE L. L..
NOTHING TAX FINANCE.
NO COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. ONE OF THE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
OKAY OTHER CONDITIONS WITHOUT
OPPOSED THE BILLING WHICH IS OUR
MOTION.
THE MOTION SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE COOPER HI.
TWO LACKEY IS AARON.
WICKS [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE SERGEANTS RECALL MISTER
LACKEY.
ON HIS WAY PERFECT AND WEEKLY AD
ON AND THIS WITH THIS ADAM
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WE'LL GO BACK AND CHECK
[inaudible] THREE YEAH
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WE NEED [inaudible]
WHICH ITEM [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible] EIGHT I GUESS
SO ISSUE NUMBER [inaudible]
EIGHT WICKS.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVENTEEN MISTER
NAZARIAN.
AND WE HAD HIM ON YEAH
[inaudible]
I MEAN [inaudible]
YES.
I THINK IT IS ALL THE YEAR.
OKAY SO.
WE FOR BUT I THINK ONE OF THE
YEAH [inaudible]
LACKEY.
ON THE PHONE.
THAT'S WHAT OUR ROOMS SO.
ON THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR ISSUES
ONE THROUGH.
TWENTY FIVE MRS THERE IN ROLL
CALL PLEASE [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND THEN ISSUE [inaudible] ONE
SHE WON HIS SHOE HAS A LIST OF
ALL ABOUT.
WE JUST DON'T THE SEPARATELY.
OKAY ISSUE. ONE FOUR EIGHT FOUR
AND THAT'S IT -- THAT WE'VE.
WE'VE GOT A LIST IN OUR ON
OTHERS TO BE HEARD -- ISSUES ONE
THREE FOUR AND FIVE ROLL CALL
PLEASE MR.
ZERO IS THERE ANY.
OKAY THAT CONCLUDES OUR HEARING.
COLON MR LUCKY THOSE WAYS WILL
WILL PAUSE MR LACKEY.
AREAS [inaudible]
EVERY WEEK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YEAH THEREFORE ACTUAL JUST.
OR MAYBE A FEW.
WEEKS [inaudible]
WELL.
THE USUAL KNOWS. EIGHT THREE
EIGHT THREE SEVENTEEN SO I THINK --
ON FOR NINE TEN ELEVEN WAS HOLD
OPEN.
HAVE YOU GOT IT ON THE OKAY.
748-451-2245 ZERO SEVEN ONE TWO
EIGHT THREE SEVEN TWO OKAY.
THE FLOWERS WE HEARD -- ROLL
CALL PLEASE MR LACKEY AN ITEM
NUMBER.
FOUR LACKEY.
OTHER NUMBER FIVE ON NINE THREE
HER MISTER LACKEY LACKEY.
ANOTHER NUMBER.
SEVEN WHICH LACKEY LOCAL.
LACKEY NO.
IN ITEMS 812-131-41516.
SEVENTEEN GREAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR HEARING